opening the subcommittee hearings for
1171.
um
i have an amendment for the bill
i mailed it out everybody
probably a week ago not everybody every
every subcommittee member and now i have
the hard copy right here
after the hearing a few issues were
uncovered uh when the
um attorneys were here so section eight
section seven that modified
to make it simpler and take out the
prohibited acts in the back
and this is an amendment i worked on
with the sponsor and the institute for
justice people
so the amendment is
20 22
0843 h
so i'd like to move forward this
amendment
you're not part of the subcommittee
wait for the full committee
yes
um i wasn't present for the um public
hearing on either of these bills because
i was testifying on my own bill and
another committee
so if if you can just like update me on
you did this because attorneys
attorneys were present they testified
that they see some issues
enforcing um i believe this section
eight prohibited act
they didn't feel comfortable this should
be part of the bill
so that's coming out so
so did you just take out
that's exactly right it comes out
yeah
eight oh i'm looking at the wrong
section sorry
um
let me check equipment six
yes representative judy is
a co-sponsor but not part of
subcommittee but he is here to help us
to cheer us up
cheers
so thank you but yes please in the full
committee please make the motions
so yeah that's where you are so did i
get a second from a subcommittee member
now a second all right thank you um
representative sentence
amendment zero eight four three
if um yeah
wood
so for no more discussion i'd like to
move it up so i'm sorry so i just
figured out
so basically
um
it's
okay the last section
the last part
you just eliminated that
the beginning of it is the same
yeah
so
did anybody um ask about
number
about the
makeup artist for the um
you know theater
are those
people
normally
not certified did anybody
bring up that or speak to that
was 16
the threading
no
no the
theatrical people the ones engaged the
ones that are doing um cosmetology
mythology related to theater and
television
line eight right in on the amendment
yeah yeah we spoke i can't i can't hear
if you don't talk
sir
yes there was testimony about that and
what did they say
well i think they said it was an
inconvenience to have to be licensed
just if you blew into town with
hollywood and wanted to
you know or were doing a tv appearance
or something
oh i'm not close enough
they regarded it as an inconvenience if
you were sort of just having a tv
appearance or hollywood production blew
into town to to find local people just
to cater to them that they would prefer
that did not have to be licensed
yeah right i think i mean i think
they might have their own people but if
they're only in for a little bit they're
probably not going to be licensed in new
hampshire
i think a lot of times they bring their
lives
sorry
yeah yeah but
um i'm i'm good with that i'm
my concern
with the whole bill has to do with um
the eyelash extension
i have that concern
because it involves glue
and
getting glue close to somebody's eye
really bothers me
and if you don't use the right kind of
glue you know
so i'm concerned about that part
and
um
and i'm
same glue issue again on the
original bill
line five
blow drying sounds fine but it defines
it it says it includes
hair extensions and sometimes those are
from what i read on the internet
sometimes those are glued in too
and
line 11.
um
i think
all right
no line 11 is fine
thank you
i'm sure we'll be discussing this build
some more
so
today but but then the amendment
so just the amendment if we can move it
forward oh just for the amendment yeah
i'm good with the amendment okay um
except for
the eyelashes
i would just like i believe in testimony
somebody said it might have been
representative mosh somebody cited an
instance of having to remove glue from
somebody who managed to glue their
eyelids shut or something uh
that yeah
okay there yes he's saying that was him
yeah
i mean i i
i'm
let us get through the amendment could
we
we will discuss it i'm sure
representative marshall i'm sure we'll
be discussing it at 10 o'clock again the
amendment is exactly the same
eyeballs together yes
there was an instance of that a child
did that thank you i remember that yeah
but just
we got to be done before tandems right
so
representative golly
thank you mr chair and i too um
i can't support the amendment as long as
this is in it okay for those reasons
thank you thank you but yeah but we'll
be discussing that i'm sure again with
the full committee
everything so all right but
vote
yeah be free
uh
i think represents anesthesia than
yourself then representative golly
fellows and myself
just the amendment vote
yes
i am also a yes
representative golly no
um
no
yes
how to be the clerk that's all
right
so
all right motion to recommend uh
with amendment
otp
second
discussion
you
i don't want to take much time but i
think you know exempting these
parts of the uh
the licensing seems reasonable to me
thank you yeah i support that i believe
this will open up the market for people
who want to do this who probably have
done it all their lives
it's a niche market for the people yeah
that want to provide the service and
there's demand clearly so thank you
and then just one more thing real quick
uh a lot of these things they don't even
teach in the 1500 hours of training so
if you get license in it you still don't
have
the education required to be safe in
these different tasks
thank you
discussion sure i'm sure on the bill
oh on the bill if you want to discuss
the bill now with the amendment
well i would just respond to that by
saying that there isn't any
you know maybe the cosmetologists that
are licensed don't have training in this
but neither do the people there's no
requirement that the um people who will
start doing this have any training
either
and they can do it without any training
thank you
there's no more discussion
we can vote
yep all right
yeah i'll vote yes
santon estasso
oh
all right
uh
do i think then it was me was it yes for
me um representative goalie no
representative fellows
no
and the chair
yes
so that would be the same as before 3-2
thank you so we're closing the hearing
on this bill we're going to
what's number
1560.
let me see pull it up
this one is a much simpler built
yeah this is a much
simpler build this is kind of a
reciprocity
um
so somebody coming in from a different
state with a current license
can participate in the profession
who is non-resident so yeah
so i'd like to move forward this bill
1560.
uh second thank you
i already described it so that's all it
is thank you
no amen no no no it's very simple thank
you
1560. yeah if you any question any
discussion please representative golly
thank you mr chair and i
too will
be voting against this i think what we
haven't current statute is uh sufficient
and needs not be changed
as long as the uh requirements
of other states are similar to ours i
think is
um
proficient um i
don't know what other states have in
mind or whether states may do to lower
the requirements but
if they are a very low standard
i'm not sure it's in the best interest
of the folks here in new hampshire to
just automatically have a reciprocity
with that state so i can't support the
change
thank you
representative fellows
so um i i agree with that exactly so if
i know that there's an effort around the
country
other state legislators are all also
seeing a bill similar to this but
but what it does is it just would if one
state lowers the
requirements from you know like
a thousand hours of for cosmetology for
example like a thousand hours of
training and
and they lower it to like all you have
to do is just register with us to get a
license
then
all all the states that adopt this will
suddenly have their standards plummet
and
you won't even have time to
react you know you might not even know
it happens and there's not time for the
legislators to react to that so this is
just unacceptable to me
thank you
further discussion
on this question okay
if no more discussion please
mr clerk
representative santo nestaso
yes
okay
um
me yeah i'm a yes
representative goalie no
no
representative fellows no
and the chair yes
okay so a similar result three thank you
our closing hearing oh we've got a gavel
cool
there we go
all done thank you
you'll hear it again
in a few minutes i'm sure
okay before we open the hearing
there's a couple of minor announcements
first of all the sign in sheet for the
committee members is over by
representative yakubovic
sign in there if you don't sign in
you will suffer the consequences
whatever those are whatever those are
yeah i don't
i would be more specific but i don't
know what they are
that's a different sign man i think it
is definitely you will
i think the main thing is that you will
be scolded for poor attendance
but i don't know who's doing the
scolding
um
the
was that
ah well that's fine
all right
i have no idea
okay
and in addition to the amendments going
around i have a letter i was sent by the
head of the performance audit program
regarding timing
that's for your information before we
deal with the um
there's that one house bill 11350
okay
and
yes
my plan for our executive session is to
start with the more contentious ones
because i've had several people say they
want to leave early so we will start
with the tougher ones and finish up with
the study committees
okay
and it being 11 o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on house bill 1256
and i call mr grady
are we going to have jen
oh we should have somebody introduce it
yes please representative fellowes is
our jennifer
oh jennifer's doing it okay
good morning madam chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
representative jennifer rhodes i
represent the towns of winchester
richmond marlborough swansea and troy
which is cheshire district 15.
i'm here this morning for representative
roy that asked me to introduce house
bill 1256 fn
relative to positions within the
department of military affairs and
veteran services
i do not know very much about this bill
so my understanding is there is a
gentleman that he that is here to
testify this bill so i would ask
everybody to yield your questions to the
gentleman that will speak after me
please
good morning madam chair members of the
committee for the record i am warren
perry i'm the deputy editor in general
for new hampshire's department of
military affairs and veteran services
the department uh wholeheartedly
supports the spill actually the prime
sponsor uh representative allard
submitted this bill at our request
what it does is it changes the
classification system for two of our
two of the leaders the senior leaders in
the in the department
so the cemetery director who is
currently a classified employee and the
director of the division of
community-based military programs
in 2019 rsa-110b was amended and it
created the department of military
affairs and veterans services formerly
the adjutant general's department
now the department has three major
divisions uh from a state perspective
clearly the national guard is part of
the department but from a state
perspective servicing the veterans of
the state we now have the division of
veterans services the division of
community-based military programs and
the cemetery
all three of those divisions are
authorized in existing statute
currently only the
director of the division of veteran
services is in the unclassified
personnel system the other two directors
still punch a time clock
in the past
four years the duties and
responsibilities of those two positions
that are on the classified system have
evolved significantly both in scope and
responsibility
the current paradigm is outdated
inefficient and an impediment to our
mission
accomplishment additionally so so i'll
give you a little background on how
those positions have evolved a little
bit
two sessions ago the veterans bill of
rights significantly added uh
responsibility to the division of
community-based military programs
now they have to administer a military
skills test waiver program
enable the acceptance of military
training
and ex
and experience in professional licensing
and establish a program to end
homelessness for veterans
the scope of the cemetery uh
superintendent which is how it's
currently described in uh in statute
has also uh involve evolved now he has
to plan and budget for
and coordinate some multi-million dollar
expansions at the cemetery which is
growing at almost an exponential rate
he coordinates directly with the
department of veterans affairs for
funding and policy
in recent years
we've seen the number of in when i say
recent years since 2015 the number of
people number of souls interred at the
cemetery has doubled
right so the cemeteries are going to be
25 years old in september
and in the last seven years
the
the census at the cemetery has doubled
we expect it to continue to be that high
last year was the highest number of
internments we had at the cemetery
ever
with about 1150
souls interred there
we also have executed in the last
eight years three expansions and the
next expansion to add 2 800 more column
barrier niches
will happen in fy 24.
so those two classified employees that
that lead those two divisions right they
have fixed schedules and their duties
often in require them to work outside of
those fixed schedules it just makes it
hard right so we have to punch a time
clock we have to ask for you know
changes to
uh to work schedules and those kinds of
things
moving them to the unclassified salary
system would just make it
easier more efficient
better for our mission accomplishment as
we move forward
so this is uh this is something that we
think is is uh will benefit the state
at not an additional significant
additional cost frankly they're worth it
right the incumbents that do these jobs
right now and anybody who holds these
jobs in the future will be worth it they
provide a tremendous service for the
veterans
and the citizens of the state of new
hampshire
uh before i before i uh
yield to questions and i'll take all of
your questions i would like to say that
i appreciate the the work and help of
representative fellowes who pointed out
that some of the language in the bill as
uh
as
it was originally written and introduced
had some very clunky language in it
and she has graciously uh represented
fellows has graciously
agreed to to
submit an amendment to this bill that
amendment is uh
0 2 2
0 9 6 h i think copies were available on
the table all it does is all the
amendment does is clean up the clunky
language when we submitted it to ols and
ols wrote it right so this is probably
on me as i drafted the language
and i appreciate the attention to detail
that representative fellowes
provided and her counsel which was
outstanding all it does is really delete
some of that clunky language so i
imagine as you work through the
executive session of the bill you'll be
able to address that and
it should clean up that clunky language
that concludes my testimony and i'm
happy to answer any of your questions
thank you very much representative
o'brien
thank you i understand what you're
trying to do uh these positions that
you're trying to change
into this new format are they under any
type of pension system that could be
affected with these type of changes
our good intentions could cause a
blowback
so the answer is they are they are part
of the state's pension system but it my
understanding is based on changes to the
current law that they will
the way it's written now that will not
disadvantage them making this change
yes
classified and unclassified employees
both are covered under the pension
system
other questions
and
if i could clarify one other point
mountain chairs that they also recently
said that they could keep their vacation
earned so we don't we won't have to pay
them out
the law changed recently so any vacation
that they've earned we don't have to pay
them out for that vacation they can roll
it into the unclassified system and
either use it or be paid out later in
in their career
okay
other questions
right seeing none thank you very much
thank you very much for your favorable
consideration of this bill okay mr grady
good morning madam chair ladies and
gentlemen of the committee for the
record my name is kevin grady i am a
25-year veteran of our air force and i'm
a 23-year veteran of the town of
hooksett been living there for the last
23 years today i'm here representing the
state veterans advisory committee we're
charred chartered by state rsa to
take a look at bills and then come tell
you what we think the veteran community
thinks of this bill we unanimously do
support this bill
and if if the committee will indulge me
just a minute i'd like to give you just
a small history lesson on how we got to
where we are today on this
in december of 2016 governor elect
sununu attended our state veterans
advisory committee and he asked us a
question that frankly we couldn't answer
and that question was
if i have a veteran who has a problem
who do i send them to
and we all looked at each other and said
well i guess it sort of depends on what
the problem is and and we can probably
figure it out and and the governor said
you know that really is not is not what
i'm looking for i'm looking for as we
used to say in the military the single
belly button i can push to get things
done
and that that sort of
impetus resulted in the the act two
years ago or in 2019 that with the 2019
session that created the department of
military affairs and veterans services
and we we realized all along as we were
doing this and the bill was changing and
everything else that there would be some
things we would need to clean up a
little bit once this is all done
and this bill is part of that cleanup
process
i know both of the people involved in in
this personally they are very hard
working folks and as
as mr perry said they frequently do a
lot of things that don't necessarily
line up with a nine to five schedule
i'll give you a couple of examples my uh
my my association of graduates of the
air force academy group wanted to do a
community service project and so we
reached out to sean buck at the veterans
cemetery and he said i've got a group of
folks from gold star mothers that are
going to come in and clean gravestones
uh in a week and so we brought our group
and combined with them and between the
three of us we are between the two
groups we cleaned about a third of the
of the headstones in one in one weekend
but he had to be there and members of
his staff had to be there to help us on
a weekend to get that done
when you have a job that is you know
community relations oriented like amy
cook's job is a lot of the things she
needs to attend the meetings she goes to
those kinds of things occur after hours
because the people that are doing those
kind of volunteer things for our
veterans in the community are have a job
during the day i'm certain everyone in
this room can can appreciate that given
the time that you give up to do this
the last reason that we really support
this bill is thinking big picture
although we really like the job that
sean and amy are doing you know things
change you know opportunities arise
they're not always going to be in that
position and i think that when we look
down the road
we're going to be able to attract
a lot more qualified candidates if if
this is
a salaried position rather than a time
clock position i think we're we're just
going to set ourselves up for success
better that way so unless there are any
questions that's really all i wanted to
say to you this morning thank you madam
chair thank you are there questions
okay i don't see any thank you very much
thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1256
since there's nobody here
all right in that case i'm closing the
public hearing
and
i'm going to go into executive session
and ask representative fellows to make a
motion
i'm just looking for the bill number
i'd like to make a motion of ought to
pass for
house bill
wait a minute a minute
wait just give me a second 12.
what's the number it's not on my list
because we we were just hearing it this
morning oh this one oh
um i'd like to make a motion of ought to
pass on i'd like to
ought to pass for house bill
house bill 1256
thank you
i would like to offer amendment
number
2022-0
[Music]
as an amendment
thank you is there a second
second
from representative o'brien okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative fellows
um yes on the amendment
um the purpose of the amendment um
was to just clean up the language
the way it was originally drafted had
some grammatical errors um the end the
most notable one was
the phrase that said duties are listed
below and there was no below the duties
were actually in the next section
so that's just to clean up the bill the
amendment
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
representative o'brien or your second
i am fine i think uh she purposely
stated it thank you
okay is there any discussion questions
or comments on the amendment
okay seeing none
the motion is to pass amendment zero
nine six nine h to house bill 1256 and
the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative jacobovich
yes
representative leckus yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzaro yes
representative sanchez
yes
representative goalie
representative schuett
yes
representative judy
mr
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair
yes 19-0 for the amendment
okay
the motion passes 19-0 uh representative
fellows do you wish to make a motion i
moved that we recommend ought to pass
for house bill
with
amendment 0969
and i'll second that okay
is there the motion is ought to pass
with amendment by representative fellows
second by representative pearson is
there any discussion debate or
or questions or comments
okay
if there are no questions the clerk can
call the rule when he's ready
representative rhodes yes
clerk yes representative pearson yes
representative jacobovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
zara yes representative santa anastasia
yes
representative goalie yes
representative short
yes
representative judy oui
uh representative horrigan yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative plunkno yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes and the
chair yes
at 1900 as okay the motion passes 19 to
zero are there any objections to consent
all right seeing none we will put it on
consent
um
and thank you all for being so
incredibly efficient we now have a short
break before we can go to the
executive session on our other bills
well actually now you know because if
it's noticed that that can happen at any
time
oh okay
thank you all for your scheduling
comments representative
representative fellows i'd appreciate
your committee report
today
okay
you
today
okay
it won't be on to this week's but it
could be next week's which will be
some combination of wednesday thursday
and friday
okay
so
representative rhodes you have a motion
on house bill 1171
madam chair yes just i just want to make
sure we
do things correctly but it's my
understanding that the rest of these
bills are time certain for exec session
i'm not sure we can go forward
that's what i was thought also if it's
noticed on the public hearing that exact
sessions could occur at any time
that's
yeah i
i think that is correct
um i think we should take a break
if anyone wants them there are muffins
in the office because we're going to go
through at least five bills before we
break for lunch
and representative fellows can work on
our committee reports
we'll take at least a 15-minute break
and i will call the clerk and find out
the stuff
that we know we can handle i mean sit
here for half an
hour let me
give
paul waste yes exactly
i knew we could do this
all right welcome to edna hi
glad we waited there's a
lot of people here
okay representative rhodes you have a
motion on house bill 1171
thank you madam chairman i actually have
in
like to pass amendment to house bill
1171 which is two zero two two zero
eight four three h
okay is there a second
yes
would you run that number by me again
yes it is
two zero two two
zero eight four three eight
okay is there a second
second
thank you
you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam chairman
basically the amendment was clarifying
some of the
issues or concerns or the the language
that was brought up during the testimony
it's it's pretty straightforward it just
basically is saying that
persons engage in blow-drying styling
hair styling
there's not going to be any kind of
chemical services and
describing about if there's going to be
any products that would be offered for
sale
okay thank you very much that's perfect
no nothing
further okay
is there any discussion representative
grota
on section um
15 persons who demonstrate the use of
cosmetic aid
beauty aid or equipment
what does that mean how do you
demonstrate the use of oh you mean like
makeup applications is that what you
mean
i don't know what that means
is it okay if i answer that madam
chairman please answer that question
yeah so thank you for the question so
have you ever um
when you i shouldn't say when
if you walk through a mall and you'll
sometimes see the
um the people that will be demonstrating
a straightener or a particular curling
iron
those people necessarily are not
licensed but they're they're they're
demonstrating how a product works so if
you had one of these dry bars and
somebody wanted to possibly buy say a
straightener that you were using
that would be an example that they might
have used the straightener
on your hair and then they have it for
sale in there
and their dry bar
i have a con
this is an expert follow-up sorry
follow-up
it says
these are exceptions
it doesn't say
that 15 is am i just like overthinking
this 15 is not tied into 14 in any way
because
what we're saying is people who engage
in blow dry styling and hair styling are
exempt from the license
and then we say persons who demonstrate
the use of cosmetic beauty aid or
equipment for the purpose
to the public such beauty equipment
that's exempt but those people could
also be working in the mall right is
that what you're saying
all of those exemptions are independent
but a person may
qualify
under more that may perform more than
one of those tasks right
so my concern with this is that we still
have eyelash extension application and
i'm not in support of this amendment as
long as it involves chemicals in any way
and you have to stick those eyelashes on
with glue
and that's a chemical and it's near the
eye
and i'm sorry to see this again in here
so i would not support this amendment
based on that thank you
okay thank you
representative horrigan
let's just have a quick question
representative rhodes referred to a dry
bar and i did actually
i was actually here substituting that
day and i guess i heard the whole
hearing on youtube while driving over
here so what exactly is a dry bar and
a blow dry bar a blow dryer where
someone goes to get their hair styled
but not
colored or permed and okay that's that
correct representative
thank you so
the
one of these particular
businesses would not offer
you would not be able to go and have
your hair permed you'd not be able to
have your hair colored you would not be
able to have your hair cut
there would not be any any kind of of
chemical service at all whereas if you
go into a salon you very well may
walk out and have some kind of a
chemical burn that that unfortunately
does happen regardless of how long a
person is licensed it happens
this would not that would not be able to
happen here and as far as the eyelash
extensions um i've been trying to find
what these actual 10 states are but i'm
unfortunate i'm having trouble but i do
know that we are only one of 10 states
that still require that you have to have
a license to do that
and as an example california i think we
would all agree is an incredibly
regulated state and they have
eyelash bars
everywhere it's it's one of the new
trends that you see popping up all over
hollywood and you do not have to have a
license to open up one of those
kind of places and in here you would be
able to do that if you wanted
and well so why do we thank you thanks
one follow-up
okay representative marsh uh yes thank
you madam chair i'll be very brief i
don't think i can support amendment zero
eight four three h however i could
support the bill with the prime sponsors
amendment zero five zero seven h uh for
many of the reasons that have already
been set thank you
and i'm jeff
yes thank you representative judy
yes uh i'm going to echo the same thing
like uh opposite marsh
i am a sponsor of the bill
but the this part here in the armament
person engage
in eyelash extension application
uh
someone going to use glue
[Music]
and that person eyes
without a license
that trouble me
i will vote yes for the bill but no for
the amendment because of this part here
thank you representative judy
representative lackas
um maybe i'm confused but i'm looking at
the original bill and it appears that it
includes the eyelash extension the
original bill so i don't know the
amendment affects that
is that am i missing something
representative rhodes if you could
explain that
thank you you you're not missing
something it is in the original bill
representative allegro
i don't really pay much attention when i
go down that aisle in the grocery store
but um
are not eyelash extension
kits also
on sale to the general public in cvs and
places like that
yes they are so
basically you you are able to go into
any store
and you could buy
a box of hair color and you could go
home and do that yourself now those do
have
they are not is i would say as potent
is necessarily whenever you go in and
have your hair done in a professional
salon however bleaches bleach
and the peroxide that is used as
you know developer i should say is used
is the same
they do have different strands of it 10
20 30 and so forth
you can go in and
buy eyelashes and yes it does come with
glue but some of course are magnetic and
so forth as as far as the the potency of
that particular glue i i don't i don't
know i'm not an expert in that but i do
know that
it also would require
you know adult supervision if you're a
child so we did have
the representative did speak of having
somebody that came in and had that
happen where there was an issue with the
glue
i don't know the age of that person
but i would have to think that if
somebody was going in and having eyelash
extensions
put on they would at least be of age to
be able to have that done or have an
adult say it was okay
president
thank you um during the testimony i did
object to chemicals in this bill and so
um
i
had hoped that we would take the eyelash
extension out and for clarification i
like eyelash extension
and artificial lashes that you buy at
the grocery store are quite two very
different things
the eyelash extension are individuals
hairs that are glued to the individual
eyelash
and it's done very quickly and it's done
with a very different kind of glue that
you would buy on the supermarket shelves
so i'm sorry that
there's this misunderstanding
but eyelash extensions are quite
different from the things that you buy
at the grocery store and the chemicals
involved the glue involved
is uh significantly stronger because
they stay on
for at least a month
thank you
for that i wasn't certainly was not
aware of that for one
any other comments or questions
discussion representative fellows
um i'm not going to repeat the things
that have already been said but on
the original bill on line five of the
first page
it defines blow drying as including
hair extensions
and
i just don't in which
can be applied with glue also and i just
i just think that
including
extra things
under blow drying other than just a
description of blow drying is
not a good idea
other other questions comments
discussions
all right seeing none
the motion on the floor is adoption of
amendment zero eight four three h to
house bill 1171 and the clerk can call
the roll
representative rhodes yes
clark wrote yes representative pearson
yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes represent
lazaro yes
representative santa anastasia yes
representative goalie no
representation no representative judy
not mr representative oregon no
representative march
no representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot no
representative grota
no
representative o'brien no
did the chair
yes
uh 11 8 the motion passes 11 to 8
representative rhodes
you ever have a motion thank you madam
chairman imove ought to pass for house
bill 1171
as amended
yes
in lieu of representative schmidt i will
tell you that's with amendment
at least in this committee
is there a second
yes
represent thank you representative
do you wish to speak to your motion
thank you madam chair so we
during the the testimony and even what
we've just heard with with the amendment
there's
i think if your mind is already met up
your mind is already made up however if
it is not there's a couple of things i
would really like to point out and one
of them is that
this would not allow somebody to go in
and have their hair cut you're not going
to have your hair colored
you are going to go in and have your
hair styled as if you were going on if
you're going to the prom maybe you're
going to be on tv for something um
the same thing with you know makeup
application there was there was talk
about if you are
you know going to be on tv doing an
interview
in the state of new hampshire you
actually would have to have a
professional license to be able to do
theoretical makeup
and
you know you can actually take classes
to do that you don't have to be licensed
in order to do that
but here you would actually have to be
licensed this would stop that this would
make somebody that
maybe used to have a cosmetology license
and for whatever reason it has it has
lapsed it's expired um they may years
later change their mind and want to be
able to get back into the profession
this this would make that possible uh it
also you would not have to go through
the entire the entire process of being
licensed in the expense that can be you
know 21 to 25 000
in in order to have that happen
um
the other thing that is very very
important that i want to point out is we
heard testimony
and it said that
they
they learn
how to identify and treat
conditions of the scalp that is
absolutely false that is illegal a
cosmetologist is not allowed in any way
shape or form to treat
a condition they are not doctors
if somebody come in and had head lice
they would have to ask that person to
leave they are not allowed to treat that
um
i think there's more on here but i think
we already have the gist of it thank you
representative judy
okay thank you representative goalie and
then marsh
thank you madam chair i'll be re real
brief
being on the subcommittee and voting
against the
earlier amendment that we had now this
ought to pass with the amendment
i will speak briefly on that amendment
as now that is part to the bill uh
dealing with the eyelash extensions
and i think we've heard
very specifically that
eyelash extensions are totally different
than eyelash kits that you buy in the
store
and i think we've heard in the testimony
uh maybe
from a member of this committee about
isla someone's eye being glued shut and
having to be open due to the
potency of the glue used
representative goalie that
although it's true that someone had to
cut an eye eyelid open it was
there was no testimony as to how that
happened
point well taken but it was brought to
our attention that that had happened
so for those reasons uh with this being
part still part of the amendment if it
had been removed i would have supported
the rest of it but i cannot with this in
the amendment thank you
thank you representative marsh uh thank
you madam chair and uh while i am
concerned about eyes being glued shut my
biggest problem with this bill is
actually a different section of the bill
it's section eight of the bill we heard
testimony from the department of justice
that this would give the attorney
general a new area of enforcement i
think the regulation of speech that is
being done in this section of the bill
could easily become a violation of the
first
amendment took it out completely
section 8
thank you very much
i'm glad to oblige
representative
thank you madam chair um
i still have concerns about the bill
just something as simple as a shampoo
some people have allergies i'm not sure
if someone who has not
had more extensive training would
recognize
if an allergy shows up
to something as simple as shampoo
i also heard during testimony that
if someone is not licensed
and a client has an issue
that it would
make it more difficult for them to
bring an action against someone who has
damaged them
so those are my concerns
thank you any other comments questions
representative rhodes are you
thank you um in in response to
to the comment that was just made
i i'm sure i would be corrected if i'm
wrong but
i believe that a person can bring legal
action pretty much against anybody
especially if there was damages done i
don't think if if you're licensed or not
would have any effect on that and
actually i would think that if you were
not and there was some damage that done
i'm pretty sure there'd be a line of
attorneys waiting to be able to bring
action against that
anyone else comments questions
uh representative fellows will then show
it yeah i would just like to add that
you know my objection is to
the um
the eyelastic extensions
because of the glue and i think that
that blow drying
could could include glue so i don't
you know i don't support that other all
also
thank you brooks i'm sure
thank you i don't want to get into a
whole debate here but
i will acknowledge that yes lawsuits are
possible however that would not prevent
the person from continuing to practice
okay anyone any other comments questions
concerns
okay in that case the motion is ought to
pass with amendment by representative
rhodes seconded by representative judy
and the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes yes
clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakovich yes
representative yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representing
lazzaro yes representative santo nastaso
yes representative goalie no
representative stewart
no representative judy
we missed you
representative horrigan no
representative marsh
no representative fellows
no
representative fontenot no
representative grota
no representative o'brien no and the
chair yes
looks like eleven eight again
okay the motion passes eleven to eight
committee is there going to be a
minority report
yes
by representative grota
it's due today
okay
and
okay in that case it will not be on
consent yes representative scitec
we voted the bill but we
we just have different levels of where
the danger is
that's all yes
cyano
acrylic adhesive is
easy to to spread around if you're
sloppy
description evaluations
representative pearson you have a motion
on house bill 1061 i do my motion is
autopass with amendment introducing
amendment 0948h
ten sixty one and sixty one
oh four
is there a second
what is that number ten sixty one the
midwives
second
okay
i'm sorry could you please repeat the
emotion i'm i was like it's a motion on
house bill 1061
and to adopt amendment 0948
h
do you wish to speak to your motion
representative pearson i do thank you
madam chair
this went to my subcommittee we
wrestled around with with the various
aspects of what we heard in
testimony in reference to
especially in reference to the the way
the board was altered in the original
bill
and in recognizing um
that that took things a little too far
the amendment restores the
midwife advisory council back to its
original makeup of six members but does
now include two alternates as we are
trying to
add alternates to the various boards
um
and it defines what the alternates
are in in reference to
um
who they alternate for
the other part was during the original
bill there were sections that were
directed
specifically to the executive director
and we felt that there were some areas
where it really should read executive
director in consultation with the
council
in those locations
that involve aspects of the specific
profession and not administrative
pursuits were amended
into or were modified in this amendment
to read executive director in
consultation with the board and that
occurred in roughly
nine or ten spots we also discovered an
error in the original drafting
in
line 24 on page three where it directed
uh the fee that was involved it
referenced a section of law that was
inappropriate
so
we fixed that to rsa 310 which is the
rsa that establishes oplc's ability to
set the renewal fees
for the various boards
that is the gist of the amendment
thank you reference rhodes do we should
speak to your second
thank you madam chairman representative
pearson said it all
okay
that's pearson wrote
yes okay any
comments questions of scitec and then
marsh uh i'll i've i'm going to take
this opportunity to say something
slightly off topic i'll say it once for
the day and that's that i've grown
increasingly uncomfortable within
consultation with who has the final word
are we talking about discipline are we
talking about i understand some of this
has already been answered but the
questions come up is this about
scope
scope practice is it
where does administration blend into
this lack of quorum business i think
this is the it is a
difficult issue i'm not sure i'm happy
with this solution i don't i'm not going
to man the ramparts on this thing but
i'm just uncomfortable with in
consultation with as a substitute for a
more thorough analysis of how this
situation should be handled on these
on these
orphan boards and i'm i'm done for the
day on that topic
thank you representative
uh thank you madam chair unfortunately i
don't think i can support either this
amendment or the bill as amended
unlike many of the boards that we've
been discussing today this was not
brought to us because of a quorum issue
opal say tell us that and they sent us a
letter dated january 20 20th that the
reason they brought this to us is their
concern about anti-trust issues is
brought forward by north carolina state
board of dental examiners versus the ftc
uh
i think those concerns are overblown
because the midwives in new hampshire
are providing a service at a lower cost
than the alternatives they're providing
it in some of the maternity deserts of
the state where women do not have good
access to maternity care for instance
where i live it is well over an hour's
drive to where maternity care would be
accessible and that's highly problematic
for a great many of the young families
in the state of new hampshire i don't
believe this bill is ready at this time
i think that what we ought to do is send
this bill to interim study and i will
not be voting in favor either of the
amendment or of the bill
thank you
other comments representative schuett
thank you madam chair
i will be voting for the amendment
because it does make the bill better
i tend to agree with representative
marsh that
we got an awful lot of feedback from
not only
midwives but
many of their clients that they're not
happy with
what they see as a loss of autonomy over
the profession
and i also will point out to
representative scitec's comments
that
we are hopeful that we'll be able to
come up with a
a group of this committee in the senate
the body on the other side of the aisle
to
oversee what's going on at oplc
in a in an opportunity for the boards to
have a place to
bring issues that they are having in in
defining the difference between
administrative
and overseeing the professions thank you
okay
i'd like to comment that
currently the oplc has a
great deal of authority over the boards
but it's not entirely clear who does
what to whom or when
and this
this bill among the others that we have
is an attempt to clarify the
responsibility
i've been reading the emails we get from
people saying we don't want state
control of midwives but
that shows a total misunderstanding of
the current situation which is that
midwives are
licensed by the state and controlled by
us a board established by the state and
the oplc
in a rather confusing manner so
i'm convinced that a great deal of the
opposition to this is
due to misunderstandings
and the fact that we have a very
confusing setup right now because the
oplc
has statutory authority and it's not
clear what the
how that relates to the authority of the
board this and this bill is an attempt
to straighten that out
any other comments representative laccas
briefly i i support the amendment i uh i
would have voted against the bill as
originally written but
because i understood the concerns about
the membership of the board but i can
support the amendment and then the bill
with the amendment thank you
okay anyone else
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt amendment zero nine four eight h
to house bill 1061 and the clerk can
call the roll
representative rhodes yes
clark rotis
representative pearson yes
representative yakovich yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lanzara yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes
representative
representative judy we miss you
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh no
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair
yes
eighteen to one okay the amendment is
adopted by a vote of eighteen to one
representative pearson you have a motion
i have a motion ought to pass
with amendment 0 9 4 8 h is there a
second
do you wish to speak to your
i do
i think the the chair brought up a very
good point
and it really boils down to this
if this bill doesn't pass oplc
still has authority over this board but
they do it with a in a very muddy
situation there seems to be a tremendous
amount of confusion
and complaints on both sides back and
forth
in reference to who's responsible for
what where the records are kept who's
who's performing what function and this
bill clarifies
what is the responsibility of oplc and
what is the responsibility of the board
what this bill does not do is remove it
so the choice is simple they continue to
operate in a very muddy situation or
they can operate with some structure
and that's really it the there's no
other alternative here so
i think that this
provides clarification
as to who does what it because it allows
for independent
oversight in reference to complaints
and investigations it should it should
satisfy
the ruling that came out of north
carolina
and
this will move them forward
with what i hope to be a better
relationship
with oplc because they're stuck with
oplc
thank you
representative rhodes do you wish to
speak to your second
i'm all set thank you madam chair
representative mark
uh thank you madam chair i want to
expound upon a point that representative
scitec made
this bill as amended concentrates power
in the executive director of oplc
now we may have a good person in that
position or we may have a bad person in
that situation position but if we have
someone in that position who for
whatever reason
does not want to continue midwifery in
the
way it has been practiced in new
hampshire for a great many years they
would very much have the power to make
it almost impossible for these people to
practice
that would have the unintended
consequence of removing
obstetrical care from some large areas
of the state which are currently
significantly underserved and i think
that is far too much power to
concentrate in the hands of a single
individual and therefore i do not
understand why some of the people who
otherwise would oppose government
control of
various activities in the state would be
supportive of this bill as amended so
thank you very much
i believe most of those people would be
perfectly happy to delete the
requirement for licensing midwives but
which is an entirely different matter
representative scientist if we're going
to argue about glowing eyelashes are
this is the birth of a human
being come on
um
thank you representatives excuse me
to finish
representatives show it when you get
together with the body on the other side
of the wall
see if you can come up with a template
to straighten this whole thing out okay
yes represent
just briefly representative scitec it is
in the works
other comments
madam chair yes representative pearson
it would be possible under this theory
then
for the director of oplc to eliminate
the profession of electrician it could
eliminate the profession of plumber
eliminate a whole bunch of professions
there's no there's nothing in this
statute
that directs or or makes clear in any
way that the intention is to remove this
profession and i think that is just
tremendous fear-mongering on something
that is just not happening
in this state
okay
representative allegro
i don't think there's any segment of our
society that looks down on electricians
but there is a segment of society that
looks down on midwifery
and no
the director of oplc cannot with a
single
uh swing of the acts
end the profession
but as we've seen in so many other
venues so many avenues of our lives they
can make it utterly miserable and
difficult for it to survive
so they're not quite the same but i
respectfully disagree on that one
son of golly
thank you madam chair i'll be real brief
um
well i supported the amendment i cannot
support the password amendment i think
there were a number of us who met over
at oplc and when we talked about
advisory boards we talked about ones
that were small and had troubles meeting
quorums
we didn't hear of that problem here for
a reason to make an advisory we heard
about a court case we didn't hear about
that when we were over there until this
day of the public hearing
we don't have a letter from the ag's
office
advising us whether or not that court
case would affect this decision here
so for that reason i cannot support the
bill as amended until we get further
information regarding that court case
thank you
other comments questions discussion
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 1061
and the clerk can call the world
representative rhodes yes
clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative
yes representative
yes representative allegro no
representative bailey yes
representative lazaro yes
representative santa mustafa no
representative goalie
no representative schuett
no
representative trudy not mr
representative horrigan no
representative marsh
no representative fellows
no
representative fontenot
no representative grota no
representative o'brien
no and the chair
yes
eight yeses eleven knows
the motion fails representative allegro
you have another motion yes madam chair
i would like to move this bill to
interim study please and i'll second
that motion
okay
the
motion is
interim study by representative allegro
seconded by representative marsh
do you wish to speak to your motion
briefly yes
i've expressed recently that
i have a great deal of respect for oplc
in their director
but
what i've seen recently is making me
think twice about consolidating
so much decision making
into the hands of a director
so i think this is a case where
a little more time for further
consideration really helped me to
to reach
the most informed decision and i i would
hope others will support that
thank you representative marsh
i concur with that statement and i think
i've said enough already
thank you
any further discussion comments
representative schuett
thank you madam chair uh with all due
respect to representative pearson
i think this is probably the best
outcome for this bill at this time
sure anyone else representative pearson
um this was not my bill so i don't
really have a
heartstrings moan on this one mike
what my concern is is that
interim study it means various things to
various people and we do often refer to
it as death with dignity
so
the concern that i have here is that the
relationship between the midwife board
and oplc is really bad right now
we have done nothing to repair that and
oplc lplc still has full authority over
that board so i hope that if this is
going to be interim studied that it
actually is looked at to figure out how
to make this work better between those
two agencies because they are married
and there are there's no divorce in
sight
anyone else comments represent marsh uh
yes in response to representative
pearson i i just would like to say that
i have heard from members of the board
some of whom are in attendance today
that they are perfectly willing to work
with oplc to come up with language that
is acceptable to all parties and i
personally believe that until that
happens it's not time for us to pass a
bill
thank you representative grota
thank you i think this committee has
other
bills related to oplc in interim city
and i think that the purpose of that
motion and the obligation of this
committee is to
truly
amend those bills in a way that's
acceptable
thank you anyone else comments questions
all right seeing none the motion is
interim study on house bill 1061
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative ludzara yes represents
santo nestas yes representative goalie
yes representative schuett yes
representative judy we miss you
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes the chair
yes 19-0
the motion passes 19-0 is there any
objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put this one
on consent
okay representative you have a motion on
house bill 1330.
uh yes madam chair i move to adopt the
amendment
2022-0399-h
is there a second
would you mind repeating that number
please repeat that number
it is
twenty twenty two zero three nine nine h
zero three okay got it
you should
did i have it
yes
is there a second to that motion
thank you
do you wish to speak to your motion um
yes please yes uh we had a hearing on
the amendment we had a hearing on the
bill
um
and by various indicators the
the position of medical technicians
doesn't really need to be licensed we
already have layers and layers of
institutions and persons that oversee
this profession they can't really work
on their own they work in a hospital in
the lab
um
that's why this is a
cleanup bill i don't we use that
language but this is what the amendment
does
it
takes
medical technicians out of the
professional licensure certification
office
thank you
thank you uh representative lucas do you
want to speak your second uh no thank
you
is there any further discussion
representative martian
yes uh thank you madam chair i am afraid
that i cannot support the this amendment
which in essence would repeal
the board of registration of medical
technicians the purpose of the sport is
we heard extensive testimony from
health care experts
it was to protect the public from
hepatitis c exposure as actually
happened at exeter hospital and there
have been since the institution of this
new registration there have been no
incidences of this happening in the
state of new hampshire so this was a
problem that was solved
that's not to say that we cannot improve
the board
i do believe that the minority amendment
uh which we can discuss later would
improve this bill substantially but to
actually repeal this entire uh board is
uh substantial overreach and we put the
public at risk
for significant harm that that has
happened to
numerous people in our state so thank
you for that
representative thank you madam chair so
i have the same concerns that um
representative marsh has and i just
wanted to do any of these rsas that
what was why were these rsas chosen
are these are these rsas licensure for
for medical technicians in various
professions in the medical industry i'm
trying to
i'm trying to
connect
those are the licensing rsas for various
medical professions
doctors
physicians nurses
psychologists etc
and it deletes rsa
2328 i which is the medical technician
registration
and further question please please so
underneath these rsas are there medical
technician categories or are they just
no they are it is one category
last question so in essence we are
removing the licensing procedure for
medical technicians and i don't
understand what the significance of
these rsas what's the difference between
saying this and just deleting
those that's this is simply re de re
deleting the reference to the
registration of medical technicians in
rsa 310a which is allowing telehealth
services thank you
and anyone else representative bailey
and then scitec i'm i'm not certain but
i think the notion that there haven't
been any problems since the board has
been put in place therefore
that was a solution as in the nature of
a post-hoc proctor hawk logical error
thank you representative bailey for
educating us on the proper use of lodge
representative scitec
bailey beat me to the punch
representative goalie
thank you madam chair um during the
public testimony we heard
many reasons why
we registered these individuals and the
reason why this
rsa was put in place
uh we also heard from a number of
healthcare
groups
supporting keeping this in place and not
repealing it
and i specifically asked those groups
if it was in the best interest of the
public
to register these individuals because
that's what we have licensing for here
in the state when we look at whether a
license is practical or not it's whether
it's in the best interest of the public
and public health protecting the public
and
the answer was yes
so i cannot support the amendment
to repeal the registration of these
individuals and i'll be voting against
the amendment thank you representative
scitec representative goalie i heard you
ask that question what other answer
could they possibly give as a health
professional
i believe that's a rhetorical question
thank you
i'd like to comment that as one of the
few members of the of the committee that
was here when we imposed this
registration
it was pointed out that the main purpose
of it being registration rather than a
license is that we can't define what the
what the duties are or skills of a
medical technician are because they are
highly variable
and that they are determined by the
employer which is generally a hospital
or some other medical clinic
and that the whole point of registration
was to scare off the people who would
fail the background check because the
entire medical technician industry
has a practice of in the whole medical
professions
and industry has a policy of firing
someone who performs
these
immoral at least acts if whether or not
they're illegal
and then fires them and sends them on
without
having any way to say that they are
unqualified to be in a position of trust
or
actually dealing with someone's medical
experience
and so that the thought was that we
would make it a hassle
and convince
those medical technicians with bad
records to go to other states where it's
easier to get a job
and
which is
i think violating the principle of
registration but that's my personal
opinion representative allegro thank you
i would like to uh
echo what representative scitec and
bailly uh pointed out but in less
rhetorical form
when we ask if we're protecting the
public with an action
um you know it's easy to to focus on
the specific group that's receiving
those circums those services at that
time
there's a bigger question are we
protecting the public in general and
that goes to representative scitec's uh
point and to representative bailey's
point he's absolutely right if we voted
to all wear a pocket handkerchief
after that accident um the result
probably would have been the same that
there would have been a reduction in
those incidents
thank you
representative
it was a criminal act it wasn't an
accident
yes exactly it was a criminal act or
actually a series of criminal acts
uh anyone else have a comment
discussion
okay i think positions are settled
the motion is to adopt amendment 0399
to house bill 1330 and the clerk can
call the rule
representative rhodes
yes
clark votes yes representative pearson
yes representative yakovich yes
representative electus yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzaro yes representative santo nestasa
yes representative goalie no
representative shooter schuett no
representative judy
no representative no representative
marsh no representative fellows no
representative font no no representative
grota
no representative o'brien no the chair
yes
all right adoption of the amendment the
amendment is adopted on a vote of ten to
nine
representative cube of it
a motion to
pass the bill with amendment
hb
1330. okay is there a second
representative
do you wish to speak to your motion
i believe we discussed everything about
this
numerous times so all right thank you
roxanna
i agree
okay is there anyone who wishes to speak
to the bill as amended
all right seeing none since the
amendment replaces the bill the motion
is to pass house bill 1330 with
amendment
zero three nine nine h
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes representative
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes representative
yes representative yes representative
yes representative bailey yes
representative representative lonzaro
yes representative santo nastasso yes
representative goalie
no
representative uh short
representative judy no representative
oregon no representative marsh no
representative fellows no representative
no no representative grota no
representative o'brien no and the chair
yes 10 9 on the what to pass of the men
all right
the motion passes 10 to 9
uh will there be a minority report yes
there will be okay representative
marshal will write a minority report due
today it's already written missed
medicine ah thank you
i appreciate that
okay well that will not be on
consent
okay
representative rhodes you have a motion
on house bill 1560
i believe i do
no way thank you madam chair i move um
ought to pass on house bill 1560.
the judy seconds okay thank you
do you wish to speak to your motion
yes madam chairman thank you um so house
bill 1560
is
is not trying to take away any kind of
licenses or hoping any kind of
businesses without a cosmetology license
this bill is actually making it easier
for those individuals that are already
licensed in another state
to
be able to operate in new hampshire if
they are already licensed so basically
we're talking about the reciprocity
if you have a license in another state
when you move to new hampshire
it is actually quite difficult to obtain
a new hampshire license
as an example
you have to
have the the documentation from the
school you've where you have obtained a
license
if you already have it and you've passed
the test i'm not really sure why you
have to go back and be able to get the
transcripts from that particular school
sometimes the school is closed
there's many many examples i personally
fell into that i
the school i graduated from closed like
a month later
you have to be able to have proof of
your high school diploma
same thing high school sometimes close
the the other thing that we need to keep
in mind is
your skill or your license does not
change when you cross a state line
you're still doing the exact same
service you're just doing it in a
different state
some states
that do require more licensing hours
as an example if you live in vermont
and you
attend a school in new hampshire
the reason you have to have more hours
isn't because you necessarily wanted to
have more hours it's because that's the
amount of hours that were required in
order to graduate and we heard testimony
that was saying that these people wanted
more hours because it was more training
when the reality is that
that is what was required for them to be
able to graduate so basically you know
if you move to new hampshire and you
want to continue driving a car
you're able to do that you have to go
take the test you know pass your past
the um the state laws and you and you
drive
so i'm not really sure why new hampshire
is making it quite so difficult but i
think at the end of the day we want to
we want to promote entrepreneurship and
we want people to be able to continue
earning a living and not make it more
difficult once they cross the state line
representative judy
yeah it was not the word says everything
so i don't have to to go there we are
hungry now
thank you representative grota you had a
comment i just have a question on the
reciprocity is it is this bill in line
with other bills where we've
um
allowed for the same kind of reciprocity
a pretty much except that
for real estate we require
new hampshire specific law tests
the cosmetology industry doesn't have
any new hampshire-specific
laws that they need to be aware of
thank you
representative marsh and then goalie and
phillips thank you madam chair uh i
think i can agree with all the comments
that were previously made i just
question whether they're pertinent to
the bills that we see before us if we
look at this bill what it does is it
removes the phrase other states
licensing requirements are substantially
equivalent to or higher than those of
this state and replaces them with
applicant holds a current and valid
license
that doesn't address any of the concerns
that were addressed previously all it
does is it means if they have a license
somewhere else we're going to give them
a license here whether or not their
license is for something that's totally
unequivalent
so i don't think that's really what
we're intended to do
um and and i don't see how that's any
different from just repealing the
licensing requirement altogether so i
don't think this bill is ready in its
current form and i cannot support it
thank you
represent goalie
thank you madam chair and i too cannot
support this
we set standards here
in new hampshire for a reason and when
we look at those standards
we like to make sure that those are
licensed under the standards we set
by the way they're done this
doesn't keep those standards in place it
just says as long as they're licensed no
matter what the credentials were coming
forward
no longer having them equal to or higher
than new hampshire standards
and just for the second part uh if you
look at that language i just it caught
my eye when we were talking about
midwifery
that same language is in
that statute as well and it says the
exact same thing reciprocity
applicant who is licensed by any other
state provided that states licensing or
certification requirements are
substantially equivalent or higher to
those uh of the state so we have it in
other statutes and i think we should
keep it there thank you
representative fellows
um my comment is on this along the same
line um the current language allows for
a substantially equivalent so for
example if a cosmetology
person wanted to get licensed in new
hampshire and the hours required
for
an apprenticeship or the program was
10 percent less i assume that that would
qualify as substantial but what this
does is it opens the door
for
some other state and we might not even
know about it right away
decides that they don't need to license
cosmetologists at all they're just going
to register them and then instantly the
state of new hampshire has that as their
standard
and
with no prior notice not even time for a
legislature to say no no no we don't
want that it'll be too late so this just
is not workable as far as i'm concerned
i'd like to comment that the phrase
substantially equivalent
is rather subjective and in many cases
there have been very subjective
decisions made
that
a person who was not concerned about
bringing in more people to compete with
their business
might not think were not substantially
equivalent their people have been denied
their um
denied a license
for
reasons that some people would think
invalid
and also as representative rhodes
mentioned there's
the
absolute hassle
of getting the documentation required
and
which we removed when we
dealt with
the
mental health workers we deleted the
requirement that
we we
made explicit in statute that someone
with a license from another
location did not have to provide their
transcripts their supervision reports
and other things that a
person who's been in the profession for
a long time
is going to have trouble locating and
verifying i mean i know i couldn't find
my
high school diploma and i'm not sure i
could find my college diploma
so i'm i'm concerned that that
requirement in our statute is too vague
and two offers too much opportunity for
self-serving decisions
and too subjective and so i'm going up
in favor of repealing that
representative fellows
i
i just wanted to say that
i agree substantial can be subjective
but in terms of having to find
diplomas or you know proof that you pass
to test
the individual wouldn't have to do that
they'd just if that state that they're
coming from had that requirement they
they wouldn't have to produce those
documents for a second time
representative road
thank you
thank you madam chairman so a couple
things i would like to point out is if
you if if anybody in the committee has
not looked up the reciprocity agreements
to have a new hampshire cosmetology
license i would encourage you to do that
honestly it is not as simple it is not
simple at all so as an example if i have
a license in pennsylvania and i moved to
new hampshire
i would have to have a letter verifying
my school and my training
if i that is keep in mind if i come with
a current
license a current cosmetology license
for the state of pennsylvania
if i come here and i want to continue
practicing i would have to show the
verification of the school i went to
if that school closes you are not able
to obtain that so the fact that you have
that current cosmetology license is
almost pointless
you have to show your copy of your high
school diploma
again if you already have that current
license you you're not doing anything
different and one of the biggest things
i would like to point out for everybody
to pay attention to
is
you do not have to take the state laws
test in the state of new hampshire to
say that you understand the difference
between the laws in new hampshire and
what other state you already came from
so this is not about laws this comes
down to skill the skill is exactly the
same thing
represents
i do come from the commonwealth of
pennsylvania
the
what i'd love to see
we debate in these four walls this is
the world i have a completely different
slant on this has anybody actually
looked up and said wyoming has less
standards and we can't trust somebody
from wyoming it'd be nice to have a list
of the states that we don't trust you
know is there such a truck is there such
a state
among our 50 representative psychic the
boards are have been requested on
multiple occasions to identify states
where
the
requirements are not substantially
equivalent and most of them have
declined to do so
thank you madam chair
again i would like to agree with
representative rhodes as the issues that
she had transferring her license however
this does not appear to me to be a
problem with statute it appears to be a
problem with the rules that are
implementing the statute and that is an
entirely different question i don't
think we need to give up
the requirement that the other states
licensing requirements are substantially
equivalent
thank you
anyone else
representative fellows yes i i don't
mean to drag this out but
the situation that representative marsh
just explained is is that the reason
that it's hard to get the cosmetology
license because the board hasn't
specified that
pennsylvania or any other particular
state is is
similar or substantially similar and
it's not you deal with each
person
individually
which is grossly inefficient
and
for example in massachusetts
they require only a thousand hours of
training which
for the
areas of public safety
are probably quite adequate the
national organization has said a
thousand dollars is appropriate
anyone else representative
yeah so i'm scrolling through the street
requirements for cosmetology as we're
talking through this and i don't really
have an issue with
if someone has a state license from
another
state
having them get a new hampshire state
license doesn't seem to be an issue to
me because as i'm scrolling through
there isn't one state other than
massachusetts that requires less than a
thousand hours and
i don't i think that new hampshire falls
in line with the rest of the country so
i in my opinion if there's a licensed
cosmetologist in
another state i wouldn't have a problem
with them having a license in new
hampshire
oregon
well this is beyond
the scope of an amendment to this bill
or at least to be non-germane but if
there's a
problem with professional schools in
cosmetology or any other field
closing and then not uh
depositing the records with a surviving
institution then that's probably
something that
would be a useful subject for bill
because i know if with colleges and high
schools even if your college or high
school closes they usually deposit their
records with
another institution so so if that's not
the case with professional or trade
schools then it probably should be
thank you
i agree with you that a wise procedure
but totally irrelevant representative
scitec how are we going to enforce that
in oregon school closes
exactly thank you
does anyone else have a comment or a
question about the bill
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass on house bill 1560 by
representative rhodes and the clerk can
call the role
representative rhodes
yes clark vote yes representative
pearson yes representative jacob yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lanzaro yes
representative santo anastasia yes
representative goalie no representative
short
no representative judy we you
representative horrigan no
representative marsh
no representative fellows
no representative font no no
representative grota yes
representative o'brien
no
and the chair
yes
12 7.
twelve seven okay the motion passes 12
to seven will there be a minority report
not seeing any is there objection to
consent
yes
there is objection to consent we'll put
this on the regular calendar
oh come on we can do it
i've looked foolish before and it'll
happen again so
i'm not too worried about it okay
that's one two three
four one more
yes
one more light bill representative
allegro do you have a motion on house
bill 1173
yeah i
i don't at this time i believe somebody
else was interested
yes madam chair
i move out to pass
yes madam chair um
so
so this is about human history this is a
fascinating fascinating topic
um
and
the people
as they appeared on the american
continent
i'll try to be very brief but there's a
lot to talk about so people originated
about 200 200 000 years in africa and
they migrated all over the planet they
traveled through
arabia through europe eurasia
so the american
peoples
got here over
siberia over the bering straits they
walked over
probably ice
down the american continent up and down
the american continent from north
america
and about 14 000 years ago they got here
those are the regional migrants those
are the indigenous people as we know
them today
other tribes um they came on foot it
took many generations to get here
it's just amazing what they did
other peoples all over the world got
as far as australia and other continents
um and then
so
the history is full of these fascinating
facts
and um on december 23rd in 1994
the united nations uh actually the
subcommission on promotion and
protection of human rights
so the general assembly of the united
nations recognized the indigenous people
and they recognized the indigenous
people's day
back then so
this is where this bill is coming from i
believe that there is time that
for the people of our lands of the
people of new hampshire
we finally extend the courtesy to them
and recognize them just the same
and that's why i'm moving out to pass on
the bill the indigenous people they
thank you
representative judy
yes thank you madam chair
i think the indigenous people
deserve to be recognized in new
hampshire
it seems like
we forgot our past
but we can forget them
thank you
comments questions
representative horrick um yes if you
recall i came in and testified against
this bill last month and i've
been a sponsor co-sponsored several
bills establishing the second monday in
october
as the indigenous people's day holiday
and that's um
that's very specifically what the
purpose of that was to try to get
official recognition for a holiday for a
celebration that's already being
celebrated that the indigent the
uh
you know the indigenous peoples in the
united states of america and uh people
like myself who have no indigenous
ancestry to speak of
that's the day we've adopted and there's
various reasons why that's controversial
but that's
that's the day they've been celebrating
so they were not
asking for permission for us to give us
just a day to celebrate they were like
trying to get official recognition for
the celebration that has already uh
has already been going on for a number
of years and in fact has probably become
more popular than columbus day so that's
um
that's why it's a proponent of uh
changing the second monday in october to
from its current name to indigenous
people's day that's why at least for me
that's not a acceptable compromise and
some
also say this is the first time if this
passes a law it's the first time we've
ever passed a law that says something
good about the u.n which uh
but
um thank you representative so anyway
we're not that's uh yes thanks
representative fellow
thank you madam chair um since you the
u.n and other countries recognize this
particular day august 9th is as an
indigenous people's day i think that
works for new hampshire also
uh it there
is some controversy in the bill about
whether or not the indigenous tribes
mentioned here are
includes all of the ones that should be
mentioned but since it says including
and it doesn't exclude anyone then i
think this bill works
better than some of the other bills
we've seen in the past
representative elect
i find it so ironic that we're willing
to paint all the indigenous peoples of
the world with the same paintbrush
like every other group
of european descent african descent
asian descent
indigenous peoples represent a wide
variety of peoples
now that includes peaceful industrious
tribes and nations
and it includes violent aggressive war
like tribes and nations
and if we're talking about columbus
we're talking about landing in the
caribbean basin
where for example the caribs uh
committed genocide and eliminated the
arrow acts
in fact what they did was they enslaved
them and they ate them
they were cannibals so before we declare
an indigenous people's days
um i think we had to carefully consider
that there were good indigenous people
and there were violent and war-like ones
and uh i'm not prepared to vote for bill
that's going to celebrate the caribs
thank you
representative black
um i understand the you know reasons
behind this bill and i'm not inherently
opposed to them but
uh as i and other people have stated
before that uh you know making things
official days is
in my view not the preferred way to
celebrate
um anything
and so and
if nothing else in support of
consistency i am not going to support
this
thank you anyone else
okay
representative scitec
just you know by the way
there's been this
these votes have not been pleasant
because there's been a lot to be said on
both sides and i'm wasting your time i'm
done
thank you anyone else
okay
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
on house bill 1173 and the clerk can
call the roll representative rhodes yes
representative ots
the clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes representative
no
representative allegro no representative
bailey
yes
representative representative lunzara
representative santo nestaso now
representative goalie
no
representative short no
representative judy we miss you
representative oregon no representative
marsh
no
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot
no
representative grota
representative o'brien no and the chair
no
two four six
eight in favor eleven opposed the motion
fails
okay the motion fails eight to eleven
does someone else have a motion
representative rhodes
thank you madam chair i move itl and
house bill 1173
is there a second
second second
bill okay representative marsh
is there any further discussion
okay
the motion isn't expecting to legislate
on house bill 1173 and the clerk can
call the roll
representative rhodes yes
you never heard a thing for an interim
study and a clerk will vote yes i guess
representative pearson no
representative yakovich no
representative electus yes
representative allegro
yes
representative bailey
no
represent ludzara
representative santa anastasia
yes
representative goalie
representative schuett
yes representative judy
representative um
horrigan
yes to the ito
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair
yes
five no's
uh 14 yeses
the motion passes
14 to 5.
i think that's probably not consent does
anyone wish to write a minority report
representative akuba which it's due
today
he's ready
he will write a minority report
lunchtime okay
all right i think we can get one one in
quickly
house bill 1395 imove interim study
second acupuncture
bye
okay
this bill has a different procedure for
administrative rules
the bill as written has some issues
but no one will say that the
administrative rule process is perfect
and i know a number of people have
expressed ideas they want to have
considered
so i'd like to
keep this bill to use as a vehicle for
study of the rulemaking process
representative lackas um i agree with
all that and also in looking over the
bill and uh talking with the sponsor
and i found i mean there's there are on
top on top of those complications
there's changes that even to do what he
wanted need have been made and were
missed so it definitely needs work thank
you
any other comments questions
okay seeing none the motion is interim
study on house bill 1395.
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes rep the clerk
votes yes representative pearson yes
representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
alonzara yes representative santo
nestaso yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett
here's to a busier summer
yes representative judy mr
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes and the chair
yes
thank you 19 to zero the motion passes
is there any objection to consent
seeing none
okay
okay we've had a request for lunch
yes
it's quarter after one we will resume at
2 p.m
i believe you have a motion on house
bill 1192
thank you madam chair uh let me grab my
papers here uh
it takes me a minute
to do
yeah i got them in order
yes relative to house bill 1192 i would
move out to pass and i would move
amendment 0913h
and when uh appropriate i'd like to
speak to my motion
represent black is second so yes
represent marsh please speak to your
motion yes i think that uh we are all we
all recognize are an agreement uh with
senate bill 282 which has passed the
other body
this amendment makes house bill uh 1192
essentially identical
to the senate bill which was passed the
only difference is we were contacted by
the board of acupuncture
licensing to add an additional phrase
to the bill
such that they don't have to
pass new legislation if the national
organization that certifies
these licensees happens to change their
name so we incorporated that additional
language into the senate language and
that's where amendment 0913 came from
thank you thank you representative
blechus yeah thank you
basically the senate did almost exactly
what we pretty much exactly what we want
to do and i uh
the acupuncturists who testified before
us did work with the senate on that and
i communicated with them
and got their assurance that they were
fine with this language
and so actually i ran into senator
reagan in the hall and thanked him for
doing our work for us
thank you
yes thank you it's always nice when that
happens
any further comments discussion
questions
yes representative pearson thank you the
only thing that i
wished we had done and we're going to
apparently have an opportunity to do it
when the senate comes over
is add an alternate to their board other
than that
rock and roll
anyone else represent black yeah well
we'll have to amend their bill anyway to
include the um the last minute change
that uh representative marsh just
mentioned so we'll have to do something
with it anyway
i i concur with that
other comments questions discussion
all right seeing none the motion is to
adopt amendment 0913h
to house bill 1192 and the clerk can
call the rolls
yes it is amendment 913 correct
representative marsh
that is correct
madam chair
am i allowed to vote on this or not
you came in before the question was
called okay thank you
on the amendment uh representative
rhodes yes
clerk four ts representative pearson yes
representative jacobovich
yes representative
yes
representative allegro yes represent
bailey
yes representative representative
alenzaro yes
rep
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
yes representative short
yes representative judy we missed you
representative
horrigan yes um yes
rep did i represent
yes okay i just want to be sure uh
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes chair
yes
okay the amendment passes 19 to zero
representative marsh
uh yes for a further motion i move out
to pass as amended
okay moved by representative marsh
second above representatives is there
any discussion comments or questions
okay
in that case the clerk can call the roll
when ready
representative rhodes
yes clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative jacobovich
yes representative lectus yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
alonzara yes representative santo
anastasi yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative
harrigan
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes
and the chair
yes
okay the motion passes 19 to zero is
there any objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put that one
on consent
madam chair if i may have a brief
consultation with you
yes
okay
so representative schuett you have a
motion on house bill 1182 yes uh i will
move out to pass on 1182
i'll second
you should speak to your motion
yes
in the absence of the prime sponsor who
we know has
health issues
representative mcguire asked me if i
would make the motion on this we did not
hear
any one representing the court reporters
that had objections to this
and it's basically in line with
the other advisory boards that she was
putting forward
and regarding i seconded and my comment
is that
as the
previous speaker said the court
reporters don't object the bill seems
straight forward
and
the question of transition is not
necessary because the
board members are appointed by the
executive director and
so she can just appoint the current
members
it's not an issue
any other questions comments discussion
over the representative pearson not to
uh
sound like a skipping record but uh i
would have liked to seen an alternate on
this board also
and if we had made any amendments we
would indeed have done so
representative
what's a skipping record
i as a as an avid collector of records i
don't like to use the term broken
because they if they're broken they
don't play at all
yes thank you
does anyone have a comment relative to
the bit
nope
thank you representative alanzar for
making everybody else feel old
okay
the motion is ought to pass on house
bill 1182 the court reporters
and the clerk can call the rule
representative rhodes yes
the clerk puts yes representative
pearson yes representative jacobovich
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
alonzara yes representative santo
nastasso yes representative goalie yes
representative stewart yes
representative judy we miss you
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh
yes
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes the chair
yes 19-0
does that the motion pass 19 to 0 and
the objection to consent
right seeing none we'll put it on
consent
okay
house bill 1079
representative pearson do you have a
motion
probably
that's the one that increased the
allowable hours for retirees oh yeah
that's right
10.79
yes
i
move
to itl
second
okay move by representative pearson
second by representative goalie to itl
do you wish to speak to your motion i do
thank you madam chair
one of the things that
we learned here
a couple things we learned in the
attempt here to increase hours
was one this would in in essence allow
teachers to work full-time
and collect their retirement
simultaneously which was
certainly not the intent
and also too we learned that with the
affordable care act
it would be possible for a community to
have to now cross that threshold as well
we heard
we had some discussions in reference to
some of the communities that do
seasonal work like hampton and rye and
places with beaches
but the summertime hours for those
per employee
to go between the holidays is only 640
hours so this the current law did not
restrict or
cause problems in any way at 1352. so
this just really
this
this doesn't do anything it gets us into
a situation of potential problems and it
doesn't
it doesn't
solve anything really communities are
free to hire as many part-time people as
they choose and this hourly restriction
is not per community it's per person so
the subcommittee felt that this was uh
there was no need of this thank you
representative
thank you madam chair and
uh while i agree with representative
pearson and very well said uh they also
the other part that uh
i had an issue with was the removing the
28-day
cooling-off period during retirement um
this was allowing those individuals to
by removing that clause allowing them to
retire in may and go right back to work
full time with the number of hours
stated if we increase them
um so that's that's not retirement in my
uh book retirement's retirement take
some time off enjoy and then if you want
to work later on in life you're more
than welcome to
so that that was one of the other issues
i had with this
piece of legislation thank you
yes and i'd like to mention that the irs
also had issues with
retire and go immediately back to work
and
there's one organization we don't want
to fall fall foul of it's the irs
any other comments questions
representative
what's wrong with teachers working
full-time and after retirement
if you're going to
advocate for double dipping
which is one of the six things that was
is in retirement legislation as a
protection we can talk about it
representative pearson we'll meet you
behind the woodshed
all right any other comments questions
all right seeing none in that case the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1079 and the clerk can call
the roll
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes for representative
pearson yes representative jacobovich
yes representative
yes
representative
uh allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lonzara yes
representative santo nestaso
yes representative goalie yes
representative show it
yes representative judy mr
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien yes the chair
yes 19-0 and ito okay 19-0 the motion
passes
any objection to consent
seeing none will put it on consent
okay
madam chair yes
if i may make a motion on house bill
okay
okay represent on house bill 1018 what
is your motion i'm intending to move
that we send it to interim study
with the idea that it's a similar
situation to the midwives bill
i know that representative pearson has
an amendment but that can also be
considered in interim study
the
members of this profession
have similar issues to the midwives
and
i was speaking with one of them before
we broke for lunch and she'd be
very happy to work with us
during interim study to perfect some
wording that will
hopefully be satisfactory to their
profession and oplc
a second
i am all set with that i'm just opening
it up so we can discuss it further thank
you
thank
the
when we went through this
and keep in mind this was also made at
the request of the director
you know there this was a this was
similar in the sense that there were
some areas in here that
the specific profession that
we needed to amend to
to say in consultation with and that's
what
an amendment i drafted
certainly does
the
that was the primary
[Music]
cusp of the situation with this with
this particular i i have
no
notes of any kind
that the profession was
objectionable to this i don't
we
all i have is a letter in support from
the office of professional licensure so
you know and again in keeping with the
idea that oplc should administer
and the boards themselves should
determine their profession that is what
the
that's what my amendment
would do
so you know if we're going to start
fundamentally
breaking oplc apart
then
and we're not going to be consistent
across the 54 boards this room is going
to be full of a lot of people
thank you uh just a question and that is
i'm not remembering but uh
other than the the executive director
requesting it were there
another question is were there any um
issues raised you know current active
problems
we were all um i mean i have the
i have the letter that was sent by
director courtney in front of me
i would have to
there's discussion about
consistency
it's also the letter also talks about as
it did in others about
clarifying responsibilities
okay thank you
oh and also too
as we've heard
systematically throughout this this term
you know the the quorum issue
representative
thank you madam chair and that's exactly
what i was going to bring up i have the
letter in front of me as well and states
that
while they're permitted to start holding
meetings may 7 2021 the board did not
hold monthly meetings in may and june
stemmer november meetings were cancelled
due to a lack of quorum
and the board did meet in july august
october and just the past month which
this was
posted in january so they did meet in
december but it seems like they did not
meet in november
so it seems like it's a quorum or a
meeting issue um unlike the midwifery
board that they're having issues with
this
thank you representative
thank you
i'm sorry the
representative of this board who was
here prior to lunches has not come back
she intimated to me that
they had missed two meetings last year
and two meetings the year before
that was it basically refuting
that testimony so i'm not sure
who's
correct
but
she was hopeful like i said that
their case could be considered
along with the midwives
in study because they do feel that they
have
issues in
dealing with oplc
as we've heard from several
president blackest
thank you um
i mean i'm inclined to
uh oppose the interim study i mean
we do have to have some interim study or
something
on the larger question of how to deal
with the relationship between the boards
the authority of the boards and oplc
you know i don't know how big the
problem is with this one meeting and
meeting their obligations apparently
there's some problem but maybe it's not
that bad my inclination would be at this
point
not to support the interim study to go
with the amendment and the bill
and then look at a larger
potential cleanup or changes to all of
them once we figure out what to do
representative so when i go to the oplc
website and i look at the board of
medical imaging and radiation
in 2020 20 they have minutes for all but
two meetings
and in 2021 they have meetings for all
but two meetings
and in 2022 they have no meetings they
have not met at all
so i understand i mean i would agree
um
and i do think that somehow this is
issue
um has to be taken up
and i don't know if
i'm going to look to those people who
have been in this
business longer than i
to recommend whether or not
we
put it in my my
tendency would be to put an interim
study
and look at it as a whole
then passing legislation that we're
going to undo later
but i oh i am so sorry
um
so
no hang on
so i'll leave it up to the committee to
convince me one way the other
representation i'm sure
thank you yeah i think the hope was
as we had
stated previously that
we're going to try and put
something in place to have oversight
over oplc
and i think that
the hope from this board was that
nothing would be done until that
is put in place
anyone else represents
has there already been
this this whole thing is the turning
into a quagmire or has the potential for
that as i mentioned earlier
has there been any discussion thought
about virtual meetings
wouldn't that solve a lot of problems i
mean we don't really have to sit around
the same table for
this uh yes that is under consideration
in other committees
represent fellows you had a comment um
yes
based on the
state of the state speech we know that
the governor wants to do something with
oplc
and um
there seems so there seems to be so much
in up in the air about
the operation of oplc and what kinds of
changes are meeting are needed i'm
thinking that
there would probably be no harm in
sending this to interim
anyone else
i'd like to comment that this is a very
new board we only passed the requirement
for licensing these people i think three
years ago
and if they can't
it doesn't encourage me to believe that
we need to license these people if they
can't
establish a board and have and have a
quorum
that that seems
it seems odd to me that they that the
newly
newly appointed and and presumably
enthusiastic members of the board don't
make the meeting
but
i would remind the chair that the two
years in question were during this
pandemic
and i imagine that
anyone in the health care field
might have had
trouble making time to attend
board meetings
in addition to their
health care duties
rip representative marsh in the grota
uh yes uh thank you and uh in response
to the chair's comments i will remind us
all that we're talking about people who
expose the public to radiation um and
considering the significant and
long-lasting harmful effects to certain
members of the public who may be exposed
to doses that are either toxic on their
own regard or are carcinogenic
or harmful in other ways
that it very much is within our mission
to protect the public to make sure that
the people who are doing these things
are competent so thank you very much
representative pearson
well the only harm here we're talking
about is if this board doesn't meet
everything stops right because you've
got folks that we have a
the entire medical field is hurting for
people
so
it's not really comforting to me that
they can
randomly go for two months at a whack
without having a meeting when when
they're trying to
you know
process
applications and licensing and whatnot
under the current makeup
thank you representative
so i'm going to correct this and i'm
going to say this again in 2020
the board met 10 out of the 12 months
and if you look at their minutes they
were they had a quorum there were people
there and they were action taken the
same in 2020 2021 so the board is
meeting
and they are meeting
in consecutive months
so i don't see that this board is
i don't know why they haven't met in
2022 yet but i don't believe that this
board has a history of being
um
of being what's the what i'm looking for
no but it has has not followed their
responsibilities i see
if you i see
from what i i'm reading that they are
meeting and they are taking action on
their responsibilities
comments represent goalie
thank you madam chair and
looking at 2021
they did not meet in
may or june
there is no one of the things i think we
need to look at when we look at the
whole operation of oplc
if if there are no items to put on the
agenda is it
isn't it reasonable that they may not
have met for that reason
and
and then the other part of my question
is
if if representative
grota is looking at minutes
in most cases
the minutes would have are approved in
the meeting after
and so it's not going to show up until
then
and also if it's not posted yet in terms
of
that's probably an administrative
function of oplc i'm not saying that
they met or they didn't meet you know
i'm just saying that we don't really
know for sure what's going on for for
this particular year
thank you representative fellows
other questions comments
if i may madam chair
[Music]
i feel like i'm speaking on behalf of
this board but i'll just tell you that
the representative of the board that was
here that i spoke with before lunch
had similar problems that the
chair of the midwifery board indicated
that
for example the
oplc had said
you know you haven't dealt with an
application from such and such
and she said
they never presented it to them to look
at so
again it's it's difficulties that the
boards are having dealing with oplc
i don't know who's right and who's wrong
but i think it's worth looking at in
more depth
okay i don't recall at the hearing
having any representatives from the
from the
uh
from the affected party
representative pearson did they support
your subcommittee
thank you no
there was no one
we no we didn't have any
concerns there was nothing
so if someone's coming now in the 11th
hour that's
it would have been much nicer if they
had been here
earlier in the process so we could at
least have had a discussion a two-way
discussion with them
i can appreciate that
i will say that i've heard from
several representatives of the boards
that they were not notified that these
bills were in the works
yes it's probably their responsibility
we didn't notify the midwives either
or the cosmetologist
so that's uh
i'm
i
ignorance of the law is no excuse as
they say it just
it just seems that if oplc was
putting these forward that they would
have at least notified the board members
okay any further comments questions
discussion
all right the motion is on house bill
1018 is interim study the clerk can call
representative rhodes no
clerk votes no
representative pearson no
representative yakubovic no
representative
no
representative allegro no
representation zara
no
representative santo nastasa
no representative goalie
no
representative short
yes
representative judy
no
representative horrigan oh
representative marsh no
representative fellows
no wait wait i changed my vote yes
interim yes
i was not paying attention
the ink wasn't dry
representative font no no
representative grota
representative grota i know
yes
push me pull you
really
one more time please
oh you want representative
i said yes oh okay i'm so sorry uh
representative i'm going back
representative font no you said no right
is that correct
uh representative o'brien
no
and the chair
and i think you might have omitted me
did i omit representative bailey so let
it be a no
okay
i recorded you without asking you
it's unacceptable it's more efficient
that way
am i that predictable
well madam chair based on the the
failure of that um
perhaps we should announce the vote
first okay uh
three in favor of interim study 16
opposed okay the motion fails 3-16
representative pearson
in lieu of that i'll move ought to pass
with uh and i'll
introduce an amendment
okay which amendment it will be
929 h
i passed out copies um
and there's plenty if i missed you
okay is there a second
second okay seconded by representative
rhodes do we should speak to your motion
reference madam chair thank you
so one of the things that uh
in keeping with
the purpose of oplc is to do
administrative things
and not run professions so
this is this is a similar concept of
going through and looking at areas that
involve
where the board where the executive
director in consultation with the board
should be doing the various function and
not the executive director alone and
that's
in its entirety what the amendment did
in
like 10 places
other than that the the amendment or the
bill stays the same
okay thank you representative rhodes do
you wish to speak
thank you madam chair okay
any other comments questions discussion
okay
i will i will mention that the amendment
also adds an alternate to the board
so that we will ensure there are
people in in on
available for uh
to fill in
any
representative bailly you sort of
suggested that might be questions i mean
doesn't this kind of
we did a lot of this last year trying to
consolidate it all to be the same and we
seem to be
pretty far into this year with this
stuff
and we've discovered suddenly that
that's not quite
right how does this get fixed ultimately
if you want them all to be the same this
is part of the actually the normal
process a couple of years ago we
essentially
shoved all the boards under oplc
and uh have been spending the last few
years finding places where we didn't do
a thorough enough job
uh
so we're cleaning up the language this
this
the thrust to make them advisory is
has been muttered about but this is the
first time it's come out into bills
and it looks like a lot because we
put each individual board into a
separate bill
to deal with it rather than having one
massive bill that would deal with you
know a large number of boards
and
be because it's easier to deal with them
one at a time
follow-up yeah
it would seem that we're introducing
inconsistencies again
and that we're
of course we're doing it this way for
one but this other way for another one
well that's why all
a number of these bills were introduced
by various members of the committee
and they are they started out as
identical
we me essentially and we made changes as
necessary
the idea of board alternates came out
during discussion and so we're adding
that in
yes
the entire
like many other sections of our laws we
really need to
wipe out and completely rewrite the
licensing statutes
but that's going to be
a horrendous job and you need somebody
dedicated to do it
if you
if you want to volunteer or start
rounding up some volunteers
i beg your pardon thank you thank you
for answering my question okay you know
it's
yes it's it looks messy but that's
because
because it is
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i thought i
saw representative scitec sticking his
chin out to take on that task but i may
be pointing
um but getting back to the bill
um
as i looked at the minutes
uh back in 2021 and
back as we go
um
you look in the minutes and you see
their task of
approving applications and renewals
and missing four months
a third of the year of the meetings when
you're approving renewals and
applications
there is an issue there when you're
looking to get people licensed in a
timely fashion
um
so that's the reason why i'm going to
support the bill as amended for those
reasons thank you thank you
we try to deal with that but still
it it something that's got to be done
other other comments questions
okay then the motion the motion is to
adopt amendment 0 9 2
9 h to house bill 1018 and the clerk can
call the roll and the plot thickens
representative rhodes yes
clerk votes yes
representative pearson yes
representative yakovich yes
representative legis yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey
yes
representative alenzara yes
representative santo nastasa yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett
yes
representative judy we miss you
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
yes
the chair
yes 19-0 on the amendment okay the
amendment passes 19-0
representative pearson
i move autopass with amendment
second
okay seconded by representative goalie
is there any do you wish to speak to
your motion
it was well covered in the debate
already
representative goalie
i just want to thank representative
pearson for
coming forward with this amendment
i think it's important to have
what we have here that when the
executive director does things that it
is in consultation with the board and
thank him for that thank you
okay any other comments questions or
okay
that case the motion is ought to pass
with amendment on house bill
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakubovic
yes representative leccas yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lonzara yes representative santo nastasa
yes representative goalie yes
representative stewart
no
representative judy we miss you
we
uh representative horrigan
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota yes representative
o'brien
yes the chair
yes
18-2
no objection to consent
okay thank you that the motion passes 18
to 1
and doesn't and without other objection
i'll put it on consent
okay
representative lackas you have a motion
on house bill 1135
and i'll have it as soon as i get to
that page
okay i'd uh
like to move uh ought to pass uh uh with
an amendment the amendment being um zero
eight four seven eight this is for house
bill 1135.
zero eight okay is there a second second
zero eight four seven eight okay
okay that's
represent fellows you seconded
oh thank you representative
do we should speak to your motion um i
do thank you um
i certainly support audits and uh you
know i wanna
hopefully find out that this program is
working well but if we're gonna
have the state spend the money on an
audit i'd like to have it be an audit
that's going to provide useful
information and um
you know as there was some discussion
before and there was a letter um
that the chair passed around from
the audit which i don't know who's it
from but
for the
legislative budget assistant i believe
that's on the back
from the audit division of the
legislative budget
stephen smith of the audit director of
the audit division
um
you know they like they want to have
at a minimum a year's worth of steady
state operation
and if they have more two three you know
or more years then they can actually do
a better job because they can look and
see trends and how things are going
so
what i want to make sure is that
this program has been in place with its
final rules for a minimum of a year
before the odds done and if it runs
longer you know somewhat longer than a
year in some ways that's better although
i i do want to know relatively soon you
know not too far not indefinitely far
out how it's going so
what this amendment does is it uh moves
the effective date out by a year
to july 1st of 2023 rather than 2022
and i understand that the audit isn't
going to occur at that point because the
whole process to go through to get the
audit going
but having it somewhat further out i
don't think is a problem i want to make
very sure that it's not going to happen
until there's been a minimum of one year
of steady state operation preferably
more thank you
okay restaurant do you wish to speak to
your second
i do thank you and i'm chair because of
the situation that we have with covet i
don't think that
um i agree that we need one year of
steady state and we were that's been
interrupted with the pandemic so i think
putting it on a year we get more
reliable data thank you
representatives i could
yeah uh when i mentioned the very same
thing to representative fellows a while
back she pointed out that as a practical
matter
no matter what they just couldn't get to
it after a full year was in place so i'm
inclined to just go forward with the
bill as it is i want to see this done as
soon as reasonably possible i i'm not
the biggest fan of education freedom
accounts but i want them
i want i want them to either be shown to
be effective or not and let's get this
taken care of
fellows thank you madam chair
um
i speak against this amendment
if we adopt
one thing to to go over
is that this bill
will put the audit in the queue
and will
assuming it pass and it will mean that
the audit will occur
it does not specify when the audit will
take place
and one thing that
the lba does not do is they would not do
two audits
at the same agency or at least for sure
the department of education i'm not sure
about hhs that's really big they would
not do two audits of the department of
education at the same time
and they have one audit in the queue
right now special ed which they
may
um if they have started it they've only
started it within just the last week or
two
so
what this bill does is it gets it in the
queue
and um
if it gets in the queue now the earliest
they would be able to start on it
would be october
and they wouldn't finish up with it
until
probably late spring
of
and the process is fairly long because
the audit is still open until they get
through all their
evaluations they write their report they
go back to the agency and the agency has
an opportunity to say
well we we think
what you said here is incorrect you
probably misunderstood the person you
were talking to
so the agency has
time which could be weeks or maybe more
to
get those issues corrected and then the
whole process is not finished
until it's presented to fiscal and
fiscal accepts the report
so that's not going to happen until
maybe
um
more than a year from now
if and it's
uh
unlike
the letter that we read is pretty much
generic it doesn't talk about
this specific audit
one of the um
reasons
to do an audit is
if there's a high potential of risk to
the state
and with education funding
like adequacy aid in this program which
is
sending a significant amount of money
out to
parents
by means of
a contractor
at to the department of education which
is a very unusual situation that has
never
happened before
that state money has gone
to a contractor directly
and there is high risk there's high risk
for
ineligible people receiving money
the money being spent
on ineligible
items
and so
i think it's important
to get this thing in the queue
and it'll go to the
audit review board first
it's not necessarily going to be the
next audit that they will do
but it gets it in the queue
delayed delaying gets it in the queue
pushes out when we will see the results
if we adopt this amendment
let's see
if we adopt this amendment the earliest
that the results could be
approved
by fiscal
would be
just before
um
we
will probably late spring of 2024 two
years from now
and
if the audit identifies
changes that need to be made
those
changes can't be made earlier than
the
24-25 school year
which is the fourth year that the
program will be in operation
and sometimes audits recommend
legislative changes that should be made
because the agency can't do it unless
they have the authority to do it
then those changes couldn't occur
before
the 25-26
school year
so given how far that pushes it out
i think it's much better to just
use the bill without the amendment and
get it in the queue
because this with this pushes it out and
makes us wait a very long time before we
see the results
thank you representative pearson
thank you madam chair um i'm going to go
the other way
on this one in the sense that when you
have a program that's new
and it's new to the state you're going
to have a learning curve
in the implementation of that program
you're going to have adjustments that
need to be made
and to see if a program works after the
initial settling is going to require
probably two or three school years worth
of data so
to actually look at what it's really
doing rather than looking at us at the
first year of implementation and
making that become the
you know the defining
study on whether this concept works or
not so i'll i mean i'm down with the
amendment but i'd even i'd even go one
year farther personally so
thank you representative lekkis and then
horrigan
thank you um yeah as i said i wouldn't
want it uh any earlier than that and a
little further out i'd be fine with uh i
thought this might be an acceptable
compromise um
i want to correct one thing and that is
the money never the parents never have
their hands on the money it is paid by
the uh con there's a contractor i agree
but it's paid by the contractor directly
to the vendor so
i mean i'm not saying things couldn't be
handled incorrectly
but i don't think the risk is as extreme
as as some people may believe
um and i really want to as i agree i
want to have things settle down so at
least you have a minimum of a good solid
school year
with the rules settled and two would
actually be better
um so there's more experience and things
are running in kind of steady state and
then we'll get a useful audit it's not
like we're going to then do another
audit on it if we do one early
that's maybe a little iffy because
things are changing we're not going to
do one anytime soon on the same subject
so
representative
um yes i
make it go on all day about this but
this is a very oddly designed program i
think probably
it was past rather
hastily but i'm not
yes
yes the uh
if we do the
um
i think the uh timeline in the original
bill as representative fellows explained
is uh is
plenty plenty long enough and so i think
um
yeah there's obviously many many
questions and i'm not even sure what the
lba could do with the contractor so but
and that which is
where most of the det most of the
problems
would be thank you so i would i would
say the uh understand the concern behind
the amendment i think the original bill
is the way to go and it still takes a
rather lengthy time to get the process
complete
i'd like to make a couple of comments
first of all nearly a very large portion
of our health and human services budget
is administered through contractors
it's not like we individually pay for
everybody we we deal with a lot of sub
of contractors in the health and human
services so it is not unheard of that we
have large programs run through
contractors
and secondly we gelcar just approved the
rules for this program
with the
proviso that the department of education
worked with the legislature to clear up
some of the areas
of con of
self-contradiction or confusion so that
we will probably see some legislative
changes due to the detailing of the
rules
there are also as i believe 17 bills to
amend or affect this program in the
education committee
plus several in the senate so
it's very difficult to do an audit when
your baseline is in that much turmoil
so that's why i'm supporting this
amendment that we should do it after we
know what the program is supposed to be
doing
representative allegro
i would like to make two points first is
that
with this amendment the bill is in the
queue
that doesn't change anything it just
puts it back in my mistaken did you say
one year
which is nothing
and secondly when you're trying to
perform a study or an audit
on how a program is working you don't
want to contaminate that with how the
program has started up
so again
uh in support of uh representative lexus
amendment
pushing it back a year is a minimum if
we want to study how the program is
running
thank you
fellows
thank you um i'd like to respond to one
of the things that
representative pearson said
that in many cases the audit of a pro of
a program
has to do with how effective the program
is so if you were trying to
you know reduce substance abuse or
you know have fewer homeless people
that makes sense
this
program does not have any outcomes in
terms of educational performance
involved
the
audit focuses on the fact of whether or
not
the money state money is being handled
properly
and if the money is being
put in the hands or have
if the money is being expended
based on what parents want to spend it
on
and if those if those parents are elig
it looks are they eligible or not are
the expenditures eligible or not is the
money being accounted for properly
so there is a great deal of risk
involved with this
because if money is being paid out to
people who are not entitled to that
money
after three years do you think you're
going to be able to get that money back
from them
so that's that's the reason for
the urgency to get it done as quickly as
possible and in quickly as possible is
still talking about like you know more
than by two years from now so
thank you representative pearson i'd
just like to focus on line four line
four says the audit shall include but is
not limited to this audit as far as its
scope
is going to most likely
wiggle a little bit based on
if we have 17 bills in the house alone
on putting parameters in when they go to
audit this program if the if there are
additional parameters involved
the auditors are not going to just turn
a blind eye to this they're going to
look at whatever whatever wiggling has
been done here so it's not specifically
tied only to a through g well actually
it since we just went through the rules
at great length we said that the
allowable expenses
are
a through n
and then o is other so
i mean there are a lot of different
things that could be covered as
allowable expenses it's the end and
if they
and that would need to be verified
whether they're approved
represent
representative fellows
thank you madam chair in terms of wiggle
room
these
this bill identifies things that need to
be covered but it also goes to the audit
review board and and they can wiggle and
they can put additional things in it
and the auditors are going to use
whatever statutes
exist at the time that they're doing the
audit so we know for sure
they're not going to start that audit
earlier than october of this year which
is after we pass our bills for this term
and it it you know it could be like
another six eight months out i mean it
might not even be in
in uh
they it won't be finished before
2003 and it may be 2004
if we get it in the queue now if we
don't get it in the queue now there
could be another education bill that
comes in and
you know gets presented and
puts in the cube before it
thank you representative elect
uh thank you yeah um
starting it in october
wouldn't necessarily make sense even i
mean the issue is the auditor testified
the person who testified said they'd
like to have a full fiscal year
with the rules set and
that's not going to start
this you know the fiscal year that's
going to include that's going to be any
part of this year
it wouldn't be until after june
of 2023 and that's why i thought the
date uh
anyway
so you and if nothing else you'd want to
do it through an entire i think uh
school year which uh more or less lines
up with the fiscal year so
i i just think you know
putting it into the queue at this point
is premature and
that's why i want the amendment thank
you all right thank you i think we've
faced off enough
any further comments questions yes
representative fellows so by the time
you get to october there will have been
two full school years and that's the
beginning of the earliest earliest
possible
time for the audit to begin
2021 and 21 22 to school full school
years
i beg to
the education freedom budget pass bill
passed with house bill 2 in 2021
less than a year from now about less
than a year ago
so we
so the 21 22 school year which we are in
the currently in the spring of is the
first year of the program
it it will have you will have two years
of
student enrollment data because the
second year they will be in
signing up for the pro the majority of
them will be signing up and enrolling
this fall so that's two years of of data
two years of student data
and in the pro the other issues their
process
representative laccas uh yeah just
briefly and
the program did start
you know uh the end of last summer more
or less but
certainly not with stable rules which
has only occurred very recently
the the
there were significant differences
between the interim rules they started
the school year with and the final rules
as approved
we've beat this dead horse
any further comments or questions
representative scitec this audit has
nothing to do with the effectiveness of
the program this is about where
where the without doing a financial
audit is where the money is going is
that correct
i believe that if you look at what the
bill specifies the audit to look at the
month where the money goes is one one of
the major items and then checking the
eligibility of the students and
expenditure
okay any other comments or questions
all right the motion is to adopt
amendment zero eight seven four to house
bill 1135 and the clerk
eight four seven well thank you i'm i
was wrong
amendment zero eight four seven
it's okay the clerk and caller
representative rhodes
yes
the clark votes no
representative pearson
yes representative yakovich
representative lekkis yes representative
allegro yes represent bailey yes
representative lanzaro yes
representative santo anastasi yes
representative goalie
no
representative stewart
representative judy no mr representative
horrigan no
representative marsh
no
representative fellows no representative
font no
no representative grota
no
representative o'brien no the chair
yes
nine nine
on the amendment
who isn't here
right now wait a minute you can't get
nine no no we can't can't do that
9 10
9 10 sorry
the amendment does not succeed
no but
nonetheless we should know what the vote
actually is
i make a motion
ought to pass
ah
fine i think we will
pause here take care of a few more bills
because i think we need to have a caucus
we can get rid of the rest of some of
our other bills before before uh
interrupting ourselves for a caucus
representative santana estasso you have
a motion on house bill 1274.
yes i'm chair i'd like to move uh itl
for 12.74
what what number
1274. do we have a second a second
representative santa nastasso do you
wish to speak to your motion
uh sure uh this is for the waste study
uh committee and
um
there was uh already a kind of a study
done on this in 2019 and there's already
state policy
to kind of cover the cover this uh so
with all the study committees it just
seems unnecessary at this time
you representative broder do you wish to
speak to your second thank you this is
being currently um part of this is
already being examined in another
uh committee facility committee so i'm
okay with um
putting this aside until we get the
results of that study committee
okay thank you does anyone else wish to
comment on house bill 1274
okay the motion is inexpediting to
legislate by representative santo de
sasso seconded by representative grota
and the clerk can call the rule
representative rhodes yes
clark puts yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovic yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative santo
anastasia
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett yes
representative judy we miss you
uh
representative horrigan yes
representative marsh
yes representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes that is 19-0
okay the motion passes 19-0
without objection we'll put it on
consent
representative bailey you have a motion
on house bill 1312 yes thank you
i'd like to move interim study on
house bill 1312.
second
bye
goalie thank you
do we should speak to your motion
representative bailey
yes
this is the one that was kind of
perplexing in that they had zero
grease input and
10 000 gallon tank for that zero input
and
i think that this bill is intended to
cut it back to uh
just to an international standard
but it didn't seem
it didn't seem like this didn't have any
gradations in a sense that you couldn't
have a 10 gallon grease tank or you know
it's like it was either all or nothing
so this maybe needs somebody to take a
look at it in more detail
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and i too agree
with everything representative bailey
said it
was
hard to
follow what happened there
because it sounded like
they either had to put in this thousand
gallon tank or they would not be
permitted
but yet
at the end of the public hearing
you had des looking over to those folks
saying well we're willing to work with
you
and that bothered me because that was
after the fact that they spent the money
and put this in for him to turn around
and say that to these individuals
and the other thing that bothered me was
listening to the hearing was that
when they go into a business that they
assume 100 percent of the grease being
used in the facility is going down the
drain and we all know that doesn't
happen you have to have a cutoff point
it's not all going down the drain
because it would cost you more to clean
out your pipes than it would to empty
that grease trap
and the final thing they got me was
when the department said they were
looking after the best interests of the
owners by giving them a bigger grease
trap so that they wouldn't have to spend
the money to have it emptied out as
often that's a business decision not
their decision
so for those three reasons i
support the interim study so we can look
further into this yes thank you
i i would like to comment that yes it is
a business decision when you clean out
your grease straps
and
what concerned me about this
was that des as you said said well we'll
work with you but their rules have
absolutely no question of
alternatives or operational workarounds
or even asking for a waiver
and so i'm very concerned that their
rules are written in a
crude one-size-fits-all manner that
entraps small businesses
and then the building control board
building code review board came in and
said well this isn't the way we should
deal with
building code issues they have to get
involved so i think the
entire
entire issue of these grease traps is
not just with des there's other people
involved and we should be looking at it
when we do the study
representative fellows
yes
one of the things i recall is it sounded
to me as if it was a visit from
hhs inspecting the food establishment
that triggered the whole thing because
it from the testimony we heard it
sounded like
the hhs person was the person who said
you need to you know
address
the grease traps situation
so we have multiple agencies that we
need to hear from
okay representative pearson we're also
in a situation of of
the a change in in both technology and
in
the value of
greece some of these rules go back quite
a ways where greece was was a more of a
pain in the butt than anything else and
now it's a it's something you sell
so
i think that we've not kept up with the
times in reference to what folks really
truly do with greece and for a new
establishment the machines that use the
grease now keeping in mind that it has
value also are more apt to retain it
than they are just to get rid of it so
this is
i think this is a case of where we were
just not caught up with the times
okay thank you representative um yep
this represent pearson athlete pointed
out um we can recycle
greece and in fact i think there's a
criminal case going on right now
where somebody is being prosecuted for
stealing greece from a well-known local
restaurant's grease traps so
you probably want as big a grease trap
as you can get if the stuff is saleable
and also
the way the bill's written it referred
to a section of plumbing code and i
looked it up and
i know nothing about plumbing i didn't
understand it but it seemed to deal with
a lot of issues other than the grease
traps per se so
yeah
okay other comments questions
issues
all right
seeing none the motion is interim study
on house bill 1312
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes uh representative uh
pearson
yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative lekkis
yes representative allegra
yes
from bailey
representative lanzarra yes
representative
yes representative goalie
yes
representative schuett
yes representative judy we miss you
representative horrigan
yes representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien yes and the
chair
yes 19 to 0. okay the motion passes 19
to 0
yes hearing no objection i'll put it on
consent
all right representative allegro you
have a motion on house bill 1344
i do mountain chair yes
i would like to motion ought to pass
for a second
i will
represent bailey's seconds okay
speak to your motion yes thank you we've
every one of us in this room have uh
had to deal at one level or another with
fine print
in all sorts of uh
things
and this bill actually is a really good
solution to a fine print problem that
could be very costly
so the the item was that um
in listing contracts for real estate
in the fine print there can be language
that indicates that
the listing agent
can actually make the sale
without getting back to in other words
without sanction from the
listing owner from the owner of the
property
so people can sign
a listing contract not thinking that
anything like this was in it
and then they're surprised by a sale
that they had no idea was coming
this bill simply says that
uh
the agent has to be proactive in
obtaining
uh power of attorney
from the uh from the owner so the owner
knows what actually happened
and knows that they're giving power of
attorney legal power of attorney under
new hampshire's laws to this listing
agent
and so i i think it's a really good bill
and it ought to pass and
if we're concerned with protecting
consumers
this is a simple one thank you
rosanna bailey do you wish to speak to
your second
he said it all thank you hey thank you
are there is there any other comments
questions representative fontenot
um
i don't think that the bill is necessary
because in new hampshire
in order to sign a purchase and sales
agreement or or a deed
the real estate broker would have to
have a legal power of attorney
so
i don't believe it can be inserted into
a listing contract
in my experience
okay that is a good point any other
comments questions issues anybody
represented fellows i just i don't
recall did anybody ever tell us that
they there was that they knew of a
specific
situation where this actually happened
because it seems like it might be just
you know
trying to fix a problem that's never
existed
i believe there were comments but they
weren't in new hampshire representative
lackas
yeah i and again i don't have notes and
i'm i'm trying to dredge my memory but i
believe represented silver mentioned
that at least there were
listing contracts that actually had that
language in it but i'm not a hundred
percent certain thank you
representative allegro then
yes to second representative lexus's
comments there
the testimony that were heard
specifically addressed that that
language can be found not at all but can
be found in new hampshire listing
contracts
and if we're looking for individual
examples well that's awful hard to do
here and now
i do i have in my notes that um
it was it was a representative silver
that brought this up
and um
he said only the owner or formal power
of attorney can sign a purchase and
sales
attorney in fact is a label given to the
power of attorney designee
and that this was uh this amendment this
bill was supported by um both the
gene archibald who was a real estate
agent
who had witnessed elderly abuse
when this hadn't been done
and she supported house bill 1344 to
prevent elderly abuse
and also the new hampshire realtors were
also
in support because it quantified two
different
documents um so those are the notes that
i have from that that helps you
representative
fellows and representative fontenot
representative scientech
i'd like to ask representative fonteno a
question will this build do any harm
i don't believe it will do any harm okay
any other comments questions
discussion
i'd have to say that i i agree that it
can't do any harm and
if it and i'm still not sure whether or
not it's necessary but if it
if it simply clarifies the intent of the
law
and puts it in a place where it's easier
for people to find that may serve some
purpose
okay anyone else
all right thank you the motion is ought
to pass by representative allegro on
house bill 1344 and the clerk can call
the role representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative yakovich
yes representative
yes representative allegro yes represent
bailey
yes representative lunzara yes
representative santos
yes representative goalie
yes
representative short
representative judy
we miss you representative horrigan no
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative font fontenot yes
representative grota
yes representative o'brien
yes and the chair
yes
looks like eighteen to one
okay the motion passes eighteen to one
is there any objection to consent
seeing none we'll put it on consent
all right house bill 1510
representative santa mustafa
uh yes i'll make a motion uh itl for
house bill 1510
is there a second
okay we're seconded by representative
rhodes
speak to your motion uh sure this is a
study committee for
the new hampshire hiring process um
and
i just think that uh
it's inherent that government is gonna
just be a little bit slower in hiring
than the private sector and
that
we just don't need a study committee for
this
you know it's just a symptom of the
overall
labor shortage that everyone's
experiencing
more than the process that's been the
same for a while
representative rhodes do you wish to
speak to your second no thank you madam
chair okay representative
psychic and then grota
did we hear that
from that other states had the same kind
of problem
i i does anybody recall that
no i don't recall that
representative grota
this this i've had i've i've thought
about this bill for some time and i
think that it's important that we
uh pass it because first of all i don't
think anything should be inherent to
anything if that's the argument that's
not in my book strong enough
number two if there's a process that um
we're doing that slows down our hiring
that can be resolved i think we should
certainly do that
number three we have a 20 percent
vacancy rate throughout our state
agencies 50 percent in corrections which
is significant
so i think that
i know that we have a low unemployment
rate
in new hampshire but if there's some way
that we can get our state agencies
employ employment
ratios up
and use that and use this lady to do so
and look at the way we do hire our
practices our hiring practices i think
that we should do that that's my
recommendation is to pass this bill okay
other comments
representative gr fellows
um i i think that there are probably
room for improvements
they
processes for
an application has to go through many
steps before a person actually gets
hired and i think there can be
improvements
but given
the current situation with
the agency having to try to you know
hire people through covid and through a
period when we know
you know there are vacancies in the
private sector also i think that this is
not the year to do this
okay thank you i represent goalie
thank you madam chair and i
will vote against the itl as well if i
recall correctly i believe we had
both the chair and vice chair of the
labor committee here before us
testifying in support of this bill
both agreeing that
it needs to be looked at
in a bipartisan way and so for that
reason i will vote against itl and
support another motion thank you
representative seitek
well the same way that we have within
our province the ability to examine
boards without anybody bothering us i
think the labor committee can do this on
their own
what concerns me
is
that this is a really in the weeds
kind of thing are we really going to get
into how the application process works
at doe it goes to this desk that desk
we're going to be shadowing these people
just
this is a committee that wants to do
global stuff they're not going to want
to sit there and sift through i just
don't see it happening i good luck but i
don't see it actually accomplishing
anything yes i'd like to expand on that
the bureau of personnel says that they
are working on this problem they have
been for a while and they are
investigating it i think that they are
fully capable of investigating the
hiring process in much greater detail
than a legislative committee
and i think they would prefer to be able
to do it without us looking over their
shoulder
and i also agree with representative
scitec that the labor committee has the
ability
to look into this on their own without
having a bill to form a special
committee to do it and i would encourage
them to do so if they feel the need
anyone else want
all right very good the motion is in
explain to legislate on house bill 1510
and the clerk can call the roll
uh representative rhodes
yes
clark wrote yes representative pearson
yes representative jacobovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative lonzaro yes
representative santo nestaso yes
representative goalie
no
representative stewart no
representative judy no mr representative
horrigan no
representative marsh
no representative fellows yes
representative fontenot
no
representative grota
representative o'brien
no
and the clerk
and chair thank you yes
sorry for the demotion
eight
uh eleven eight
two motion promote itl motion passes
eleven to eight will there be a minority
report
okay if nobody's gonna write one then
obviously not
i think it should go on the regular
calendar anyway
all right
and i think
i think we will recess for 10 minutes to
have a quick caucus on house bill 1135
rather than muttering
okay
thank you
it's actually kind of funny
just announcing to the world
yes turn your mic off
is everybody back
yeah looks like it okay
having completed all our other business
we're back on house bill 1135
and representative pearson has a motion
i'm going to
i'm going to move reconsideration on the
amendment
okay
is there a second
a point of order
did you vote on the prevailing side that
is not a condition in committee um
motions to reconsider
it is on the house floor but not in
committee
okay so representative pearson has moved
reconsideration of the
amendment seconded by representative
lackas
is there
let's see is that debatable yes
representative sciatic
is it debatable
i have no idea well we're in committee
let's debate it
well
i'll break the ice on that that was
funny
okay thank you
i
am in favor of and
of an audit i wanted it
as soon as
reasonable
things have been brought to my attention
as you might imagine
i did not read the letter
that we got from
it was on our desks maybe we got it in
email but i must have missed it with
boat speeds in winnipesaukee
um
about the
conductive audits and it makes a couple
points
that i'm
one it's best to wait for the until the
program is operational
uh for some time
representative fellows has made a good
case
i just don't know
how much time
there's a second thing
second part at the end he gives an
example of
its therapeutic cannabis identification
card program i don't know that that's
directly comparable but it's an example
of why or of
the concern about an early audit
is also
while things are being brought to my
attention
that there are bills currently
affecting this program in the works and
we're going to have um
lba is going to have a moving target if
if that's the right expression or it's
going to be amorphous how do you
nuts
so i'm gonna
i still want the audit but i'll vote for
the amendment
okay the
the motion is to reconsider our vote the
reconsideration
okay
seeing no other interest in discussion
we'll call the vote
representative rhodes
yes
yeah you have to collaborate yes
representative pearson yes
representative jacob
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes represent
bailey
yes representative lanzaro yes
representative
yes representative goalie no
no
representative judy no miss you
representative
um
no representative
marsh
no
representative fellows no representative
representative grota
no representative o'brien
no chair yes
reconsideration provides ten to nine
reconsideration prevails ten to nine so
that the next next step is to vote on
the passage of the amendment
uh number 0847
vote on the amendment we retake the vote
yes
okay
i don't think it needs a special motion
because we just voted to reconsider
uh is there any further discussion on
the amendment
representative schuett i'm just i didn't
quite get who
made the motion in second
pearson and lacas thank you
what's the parliamentary status the
parliamentary says we have voted to
reconsider and the next
action therefore is to retake the vote
of
on passing the amendment so this is the
reconsidered vote we have reconsidered
and we will now just do the recon
we will now consider it again so it is
up for debate if anyone needs
if anyone missed saying something in the
previous debate
which i don't think so okay
in that case the motion is to pass
amendment
adopt amendment 0847 h
and the clerk can call the roll room
ready
representative rhodes
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes representative
yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
linzara yes
representative santo anastasia yes
representative goalie
no
representative schuett
no representative judy
no mr
representative horrigan no
representative marsh no representative
fellows
no
representative font no no
representative grota
no representative o'brien no
chair yes
ten to nine on the inventory okay the
amendment passes ten to nine
representative lucas you have a motion
i'd like to move um
uh ought to pass uh with amendment um
zero eight four seven h on house bill
is there a second
okay seconded by representative pearson
is there any discussion
i'd like to say that doing a performance
audit of this program is a very good
idea
and i
want to thank representative fellows for
bringing this bill forward
any other comments questions discussion
all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 1135 and the clerk can call the
roll
out of pass is amended representative
rhodes yes with amendment
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative yakubovic yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative lanzaro yes
represent
yes representative goalie
no
representative stewart
no representative judy no i miss you
representative horrigan
representative mark
no
a representative
okay one at a time please don't
i've had i have recorded judy is no
horrigan is no marsha's
no
fellows representative fellas
representative font no
no
representative grota
no representative o'brien
no
the chair
yes
ten nine
okay
the motion passes ten to nine um is
there someone going to write a minority
report representative fellow so we'll
write the minority report
okay
i think that is all the bills we have in
our possession unless somebody wants to
go back up back to one of the others
all right no seeing no enthusiasm
thank you all for coming and for lasting
through this
thank you representative marsh for
sending in your committee reports
they are due today
before midnight
and
have a nice day and i'll see you all on
thursday
yes
i am going to follow it more closely i'm
probably going to be here tomorrow
afternoon i'm sure it wasn't personal
but
you know
yeah
some of it
you